Hab ich ihm gesagt, naja, du musst halt einfach einen Verein finden, den du magst, den du intensiver verfolgen möchtest. Und da hat er dann festgelegt, dass er um diese wichtige Entscheidung, die ja dann eigentlich so sein restliches Leben lang dann auch Gültigkeit haben soll, treffen zu können, sich natürlich erstmal alle Vereine anschauen muss. Und jetzt, gute sieben Jahre später, sind wir halt immer noch unterwegs und haben keinen Verein gefunden.
Also es gibt nicht eine Sache, wo ich sage, dann wird es mein Lieblingsverein, egal wie toll es ist, die anderen Bedingungen, es muss alle Bedingungen restlos erfüllen, die ich habe. Und das sind nicht wenige.
Ein weiterer Grimme Online Award 2017 in der Kategorie Kultur und Unterhaltung geht an Wochenendrebell.
Seit 2011 sucht das Vatersohn Duu Mirko und Jason nach einem Verein für den Junior. So beginnt die Geschichte der Wochenendrebellen, die inzwischen viel mehr ist als nur diese Suche. Sie bloggen, sie podcasten, sie haben ein Buch geschrieben, sie sammeln mit einer Lesetour Geld für den guten Zweck und ganz nebenbei lassen sie uns alle schlauer werden über Klimawandel, Toleranz, Quantenphysik und nicht zuletzt Autismus. Herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk, lange, lange geplant, jetzt endlich ist es soweit, Mirko und Jason von Jutta Czenka. Schön, dass ihr hier mit dabei seid. Wir haben uns wirklich sehr gefreut und wenn ich wir sage, dann meine ich endlich auch ein Wir, das mit am Tisch sitzt. Hallo Frank. Schön, dass du wieder hier bist. Ja, wir machen wieder eine unserer berühmten Vorortaufnahmen hier in meinem Wohnzimmer in den Außenstudios der Rasenfunk Headquarters. Wir wollen sprechen über euer Projekt, das Ganze ein bisschen vorstellen. Es gibt sicherlich viele da draußen, die die Wochenendrebellen, also euch beiden schon kennen, aber vielleicht auch den oder die eine oder andere, die noch nichts davon gehört hat. Bevor wir loslegen, danke ich noch Tillmann, Matos 09, Miguel, Mario aus Leipzig, dem FCSP, Till, Lothar und dem Supporter, der mit gar kein Fußballfan genannt werden wollte. Warum auch immer. Kannst du uns gerne erklären in einer E-Mail. Herzlichen Dank für euren Support, der Rasenfunk wie immer. Werbesponsoren und paywallfrei durch Unterstützer und Unterstützerinnen, wie die eben genannten. Herzlichen Dank für eure Unterstützung. Und wer erfahren möchte, wie man dem Rasenfunk finanziell helfen kann, erfährt das auf rasenfunk.de. Aber jetzt wollen wir mal reingehen in eure Geschichte, wie das alles losging. Ihr musstet es schon sehr häufig erzählen, Mirko. Deswegen nehme ich ein paar Dinge vorweg. Es ging alles los beim Spiel Leverkusen gegen Valencia. Das haben wir auch im Intro schon gehört. Damals habt ihr Jason mit ins Stadion genommen, im Alter von sechs Jahren, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Und er hat sich sehr dafür interessiert, was da die Fans gemacht haben und hat dann danach im Auto gefragt, worum es da eigentlich ging und ob er auch Fan wäre. Und dann hast du gesagt, was es auf sich hat mit dem Fantum. Und er meinte, na, um mich da entscheiden zu können, muss ich ja alle Vereine angucken. Und dann hast du gesagt, weil es schon sehr spät war, das ist gar kein Problem, das machen wir. Wählst du deine Worte seit diesem Vorfall sorgfältiger?
Aber meiner Meinung nach kostet das nicht offensiv genug aus. Was kostet das nicht offensiv genug aus? Dass wir nicht öfter irgendwie fragen oder nach solchen Ratschlägen fragen oder so.
Ja gut, wir sind ja jetzt auch die letzte Zeit nicht mehr so ganz häufig unterwegs gewesen. Das kommt ja auch noch dazu.
Aber wir sind halt auf Lesereise.
Wie viele Vereine habt ihr denn in Deutschland gesehen? Das Ziel war ja mal alle Vereine der ersten, zweiten und dritten Liga. Jetzt sind acht Jahre vergangen, das heißt, es gab auch diverse Auf- und Abstiege. Und ich weiß auch, dass sich der Fokus auch von Deutschland dann losgelöst hat. Habt ihr im Blick, wie viel ihr schon gesehen habt?
Also wenn es jetzt nur Deutschland ist, würde ich sagen, sind es jetzt so 75 Vereine ungefähr.
Die erste Liga ist voll, die zweite Liga ist fast voll, und in der dritten Liga haben wir so… Ja, da sind wir noch ein bisschen weit weg von voll.
Ich denke, da haben wir die Hälfte.
Die zweite Liga schaffen wir, glaube ich. Wenn die Laserreise vorbei ist, machen wir die zweite Liga, glaube ich, recht bald voll.
Du hast halt ein paar Standorte dabei, dadurch, dass wir ja jede… Wir haben jeden Ausflug bisher mit dem Zug gemacht. Es gab eine einzige Ausnahme, das war mit dem Fabian Schäler von der Zeit. Waren wir in Glasgow, das war mit dem Zug jetzt mal so eben am Wochenende nicht machbar. Leider, sehr cool gewesen.
Es fährt man nach Züge.
Ansonsten müssen wir jede Anreise und Abreise nur mit öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln vornehmen, also auch nicht mal so ein Stückchen Taxi oder so, das ist halt nicht mehr genehm, sodass es dann so Aue oder so was ist, was du nicht mal so eben einplanen kannst. Da musst du wirklich gucken, wann haben die ein Spiel, den Sonntag kannst du schon meistens vergessen, weil du dann gar nicht mehr zurückkommst.
Aber das Coole war, relativ in der Nähe von Aue, ich weiß gar nicht, in Grössnitz, wo liegt der längste Bahnsteig Deutschlands?
Ja, da sind wir nicht nur vorbeigefahren, da hatten wir sogar noch eine Stunde Aufenthalt.
Das war richtig cool.
Das war mega.
Ich bin die ganze Zeit nur auf und ab gelaufen. Und hast nachgemessen.
Das auch, ich bin immer lang gelaufen, hab geguckt, wie viele Schritte da sind, und ich war einfach faszinierend von diesem Bahnsteig, der war so cool.
Der gesamte Bahnhof ist auch zu empfehlen.
Da hast du dich dann wahrscheinlich noch aufgehalten. Wer fehlt denn dann in der 2. Liga noch?
Ich weiß gar nicht genau.
Hast du keine Liste, wo du alles noch mal…
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das kann doch nicht sein. Wir haben tatsächlich eine recht lose Excel-Tabelle, für die wir uns aber auch schon seit… also die wir gar nicht mehr so richtig aktuell pflegen momentan.
Aber die im Blog ist ja recht aktuell.
Nee, die im Blog ist auch nicht aktuell.
Aber doch ziemlich aktuell.
Ja, also ziemlich, wenn man sagt, da sind aus dem letzten Jahr, glaube ich, ein oder zwei Einträge drin, würde ich jetzt schätzen.
Wir waren auch im letzten Jahr nicht viel öfter als ein oder zwei Mal.
Wir waren schon deutlich häufiger. Nee, letztes Jahr nicht. Nee, gut, dann liege ich dort irrtümlich falsch. Separat dazu erfassen wir einen Großteil über die Groundhopper-App insgesamt, die da einfach mega praktisch ist, um dort gegebenenfalls nichts… Und es gibt halt das große, was angefangen hat, als Erinnerungswand quasi. Wir haben ja am Anfang dann von jedem Spiel auch einen Schal was am Anfang. Später sind wir dann auch zum Glück auf Pins oder andere Dinge abgewichen mitgebracht, weil wenn er dann Fan von einem Verein irgendwann wird, dann muss er ja gegebenenfalls da auch dann ein Fanutensil von haben. Daraus ist dann seine Erinnerungswand geworden im Zimmer. Und aus der Erinnerungswand ist jetzt ein Erinnerungszimmer geworden, wo so Schals und alles sich so sammelt. Und da gibt es auch noch die große Kiste mit Eintrittskarten, um dann gegebenenfalls noch mal irgendwann in Ruhe den Abgleich machen zu können, welches Spiel fehlt da jetzt wo wirklich gegebenenfalls. Und in der zweiten Liga? Ich wüsste es aus dem Kopf tatsächlich jetzt nicht, wer dort unter anderem fehlen würde. Aber ihr… Heidenheim fehlt.
Aber ihr fahrt auch zu Vereinen, bei denen ihr zum Beispiel schon wisst, also Maskottchen ist ja sehr leicht rauszufinden, welcher Verein Maskottchen hat. Ihr fahrt dann dennoch hin, obwohl er ja eigentlich dann schon von der Liste ist. Das ist dann eine Unterkategorie zum übergeordneten Ziel, Fan zu werden. Und hattest du das von Anfang an bei dir, wenn wir jetzt schon vorhin darüber gesprochen haben, wie sich bei dir manchmal dann regend verändern? Und ich vermute, dass du da auch eine ganz gute Erinnerung dran hast, wie sich das verändert hat?
Also grundsätzlich, das oberste Ziel war natürlich, von der ersten Liga zu sein, aber ich war mir in dem Moment glaube ich schon relativ klar, dass dafür mindestens die komplette erste, zweite und dritte Liga notwendig sein wird, wenn nicht sogar noch mehr. Mittlerweile geht die Tendenz eher zu noch mehr, weil es dort wahrscheinlich gar keinen passenden Verein gibt. Aber es war mir schon klar, dass das ungefähr die Ausnahmemaße annehmen muss, um dort auf ein Ergebnis zu kommen.
War es dir denn von Anfang an klar, dass es ein deutscher Verein sein muss oder sein wird? Ihr seid ja dann irgendwann auch – habt ihr auch Growns außerhalb von Deutschland besucht?
Nein, das ist jetzt nicht daran gebunden. Die meisten Stadien, die wir besuchen, sind in Deutschland. Deswegen ist es statistisch wahrscheinlich recht wahrscheinlich, dass der Verein in Deutschland liegt, der es dann letztendlich wird. Aber vielleicht ist es tatsächlich so, wenn man sich herausstellen sollte, dass die Sekretärinien das alle erfüllt sind, so selten ist, dass es dann vielleicht im Ausland einige Vereine gibt. Also in England gibt es zum Beispiel die Forest Green Warriors. Die bauen jetzt ein Stadion aus Recyclingholz und von denen sind alle Spieler veganer. Also dann wäre auf jeden Fall das ökologische Kriterium vollend erfüllt.
Man müsste das Gesicht von Milko jetzt übertragen können im Podcast. Es wurde ja schon klar, dass es ein ganz schöner Aufwand ist, auch finanziell und zeitlich diese ganzen Touren. Ich habe da gerade schon eine Preisberechnung gesehen, wie man dann mit dem Zug nach England…
Das geht aber, glaube ich, mit der Zugverbindung. Ich habe eine ganze Nachtzugkarte auf Google Maps und eine eigene Karte, das sind nur Nachtzugverbindungen. Ich glaube, man kommt sogar nur mit Nachtzügen bis dahin.
Okay, also es ist inzwischen nicht mehr nur auf Deutschland beschränkt.
Ja, das Versprechen basiert weiterhin auf den ersten drei Ligen. Ich habe auch gesagt, wir gehen weiter runter, wenn es sein muss. Was das Ausland angeht, habe ich dann schon den Sicherheitsriegel drin, dass ich gesagt habe, wir fahren einmal im Jahr in den Stadion im Ausland. Da hat Jason dann gegebenenfalls nochmal vorgeschlagen, dass er gesagt hat, die Länder sollten dann zumindest wechseln.
Hast du letztes Jahr aber nicht erfüllt?
Letztes Jahr waren wir, doch, wir waren letztes Jahr, wo waren wir letztes Jahr?
Oder war letztes Jahr das Fest, irgendwas hast du letztes Jahr auf jeden Fall nicht erfüllt, was wir dieses Jahr nachholen müssen?
Festivals haben wir nicht erfüllt, letztes Jahr. Da haben wir gesagt, das müssen wir dieses oder nächstes Jahr machen. Parallel dazu gibt es noch mal so ein kleines Festivalversprechen, dass wir einmal im Jahr auf einem Festival fahren.
Oder meistens jetzt Konzerts, weil Festival mit dem Auto geht ja nicht, deswegen wird es jetzt meistens Konzert momentan.
Genau.
Und jetzt macht ihr das seit acht Jahren. Wie hat sich denn der Fußball aus eurer Zuschauersicht verändert jetzt in den acht Jahren? Kann man da Veränderungen sehen?
Was würdest du sagen? Also wir haben sicherlich glücklich angefangen. Also dadurch, dass wir im Schwerpunkt zu Beginn erste, zweite Liga hatten, die erste Liga dementsprechend mittlerweile ja gefüllt haben, ist es jetzt eher so, dass wenn wir unterwegs sind, sind wir dritte, vierte oder weiter unten unterwegs. Da ist es zum einen so, dass man, was den gesamten Stadion auftritt, den das gesamte Erlebnis angeht, durchaus auch Überraschungen erlebt. Erstmal, wie sieht es da aus? Wenn ich hier nach München in die Allianz Arena fahre, dann weiß ich, okay, ich komme da an, das wird leuchten und dann gehe ich rein und dann weiß ich in etwa, was mich dort erwartet und dann hängt sehr, sehr viel von dem Spiel dann gegebenenfalls ab. Insbesondere für Jason. Wir waren jetzt bei Göttingen 05. Da war es halt eine verrostete Sprecherkabine, die irgendwo vor sich hingammelte oben auf so einem Berg. War halt für ihn so das absolute Highlight, woran er sich so dermaßen erfreuen konnte. Und ich mittlerweile zugeben muss, dass auch ich mich an diesen Skurrilitäten dann erfreuen kann, wenn es dann noch so ein bisschen was Erdendes hat, also für das Vienna FC oder so, wenn du da dann da hinfährst. Und dann erwartest du erstmal, okay, das ist der älteste Verein Wien. Okay, da wird die Hölle los sein. Und dann spielen die da auf irgendeinem Bezirksliga-Sportplatz. Und da sind dann irgendwie 30 Fans. Aber die 30 gehen halt in der Halbzeit mit einem Dudelsack ab, dass du denkst, was ist hier los. Das sind halt so Erlebnisse, wo ich sage, die habe ich sehr, sehr positiv in Erinnerung. Was mich extrem annervt und was halt nachvollziehbarerweise aus der ersten und eigentlich auch aus der zweiten gar nicht mehr und mittlerweile auch in der dritten Liga sehr, sehr stark vertreten ist, ist halt diese durchgetaktete Kommerzialisierung, dass du eigentlich keinerlei Info übers Spiel mehr bekommst, ohne dass nicht hinten dran gehängt wird. Wer bezahlt denn diese Info jetzt? Oder von wem wird diese präsentiert? Das ist wiederum etwas, wenn das dann so exzessiv ist, dass ich mich wieder aufrege, dann findet er es schon wieder toll. Dann ist es schon wieder eine Skurrilität.
Aber du findest es dann vor allem gut, wenn dein Papa sich darüber aufregt?
Also ich glaube, das ist gar nicht grundsätzlich nur, weil Papst sich darüber aufregt, sondern er sich einfach über Dinge aufregt, die ich gut finde. beim VfW Alen wurden zum Beispiel die Eckbälle durch einen Elefanten präsentiert von der Jimbo-Auto-Wäsche. Die Jimbo-Auto-Wäsche ist eine Autowaschanlage aus Alen und wirbt in ihrem Logo mit einem Elefanten und der spritzt gerade so ein Auto mit seinem Rüsseltauber.
Hört sich absolut putzig an.
Ja, und die haben dann immer einen so Elefantengeräusch, quasi wie so eine Elefanttröte und deren Werbegeräusch und dann ist das tatsächlich immer so nach jedem Eckball. Dieser Eckball wird dann präsentiert in der Jimbo-Auto-Wasche. Und in dem Moment kommt dann auf der Anzeigtafel so ein Elefant und hört dann ganz laut aus alten kratzigen Lautsprechern diese Elefantengetröte. Oder die verletzten Spieler wurden von der Apotheke dort präsentiert. In Karlsruhe wurde die Gästemannschaftsausstellung von einer Trauerhilfe verkündet. Das finde ich dann natürlich irgendwie dann doch mal witzig.
Also weiß ich nicht, das sehe ich halt komplett anders. Also gerade so, wenn es um Spielinfos geht. Also wenn ich das Spiel schaue, dann brauche ich eigentlich auch gar keine Infos. Also dann könnten die gegebenenfalls dieser Stadionsprecher, wenn der 90 Minuten seine Klappe halten würde, wäre ich auch voll, könnte ich total gut mitleben. Wenn dann dort Infos über die Anzeigtafel kommen und da meinetwegen dann vorher noch der kurze Jingle kommt oder irgendeine Geräuschkulisse, damit man weiß, jetzt bitte auf die Anzeigtafel gucken, weil da kommt Info-Y, dann ist das für mich auch in Ordnung. Aber wenn es dann so eskaliert, das geht nicht. Das macht mich wirklich fassungslos. Da ist Aalen sicherlich die Spitze gewesen, aber das ist ja in vielen, insbesondere in den Stadien der 1. und 2. Liga, schon etwas – wir haben teilweise Eintrittskarten gehabt, wenn man so sagt, man möchte die sammeln und sich an die Wand hängen, die kannst du ja gar nicht an die Wand hängen, weil da irgendwie – was war das? Kiel war das, glaube ich. Da musste man erst mal gucken, wo steht denn die Paarung überhaupt? So ganz, ganz viele Sachen, wo ich sage, ich verstehe das, das Geld muss ja irgendwo herkommen, das ist für mich nachvollziehbar. Aber ich glaube halt, dass dort es in vielen Vereinen schon so weit ist und dass sich das vielleicht auch so weiter dreht, dass dann gerade so dritte, vierte, fünfte Ligen interessanter werden, die vielleicht auch andere Wege finden und den Fan von dem Zeug gegebenenfalls ein bisschen befreien. Das könnte ich mir schon vorschlagen.
Aber insgesamt war ja dennoch Ahlen der großartigste Ausdruck, den wir bis jetzt hatten.
Dieses Spiel Ahlen gegen Sandhausen. Bei minus viereinhalb Grad im Dezember.
Insgesamt waren es, glaube ich, sieben Stunden Anreise.
Deine Augen leuchten. Das muss man kurz transportieren. Und war es nicht dann sogar 0 zu 0? Und ihr habt ja die 0 zu 0-Regel. Darauf freue ich mich schon.
Das ist für Jason immer so das Highlight. Wenn wir auf der Lesereise unterwegs sind, dann machen wir ja quasi eine Abstimmung, welches Kapitel wir lesen. Und wenn dann das Ahlen-Kapitel gelesen wird, dann geht es halt im Nachgang um die Diskrepanz, wie wir diesen Ausflug wahrgenommen haben. Wenn er jetzt nicht dabei gewesen wäre, und es wäre wirklich etwas, wo du sagst, fährst du jetzt mal hin und guckst Fußball oder so, dass ich es mir nicht schlimmer hätte vorstellen können. Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was noch hätte passieren können, dass ich sagen würde, ich hätte es grausamer und fürchterlicher in Erinnerung. Und bei ihm ist es halt das komplette Gegenteil. Und er meint es halt wirklich hundertprozentig ernst. Also es ist ja sehr, sehr häufig, so ähnlich wie du gerade sagtest, so mit dem, ist es so, dass der Papsi sich darüber ärgert. So habe ich den Besuch zunächst wahrgenommen, dass er sich nur freut, weil ich mich ärgere. Aber nein, er fand es halt wirklich gut. Was mir halt enorme Ängste bereitet, denn für Jason sind Regeln wichtig. Und der Fahrplan muss klar sein, wo ist das Ziel, wie geht es weiter. Und er hat mich dann auch mal gefragt, als wir bei einem Spiel von Fortuna Düsseldorf waren, du Papsi, wenn ich jetzt heute Fan werde, dann ist ja alles vorbei. Dann ist ja das gesamte Projekt beendet. Und da hab ich natürlich Lunte gerochen und hab gesagt, na, mach dir da keine Sorgen. Also wenn du heute Fan von Fortuna Düsseldorf wirst, dann können wir eine Dauerkarte kaufen. Wir können eine 36er-Saison machen. Wir können ins Trainingslager fahren. Wir können in die Historie des Vereins eintauchen. Also man kann so tausende von Sachen machen. Was er dann halt aber auch adaptiert hat, dass das nicht nur für Fortuna Düsseldorf gilt, sondern halt gegebenenfalls auch für den VfL. Und das sind dann halt schon Momente, wo dir auch bei 4 Grad Minus durchaus die Schweißperlen auf der Stirn stehen, wenn du so auf die Idee kommst, so eine 36er-Saison mit dem VfL ist jetzt kein Spaß.
Aber wir müssen ja noch mal hin und da müssen wir darauf achten, ob die einen Kreis machen, weil ein Maskottchen haben sie nicht.
Aber da habe ich ja schon gesagt, den werden sie machen. Das werde ich sicherstellen.
Ich kann ja auch meinen, dass ich keinen mache.
Ich sehe schon, dass irgendwann sich die Vereine danach richten, dass Jason kommt.
Aber Papi hat doch gesagt, er würde die dafür bezahlen lassen, den Kreis machen.
Das kann man bei denen wahrscheinlich auch machen.
Das geht wahrscheinlich mittlerweile. Die sind doch jetzt noch mal abgestiegen. Also damals dieses Elefanten-Paket für die Jimbo-Auto-Beschrift.
Das war damals 699 Euro.
Genau, hat 700 Euro gekostet.
Aber du hast gesagt, du würdest das Geld erst verbrennen, dafür auszunehmen.
Ja gut, man macht ja da auch keine Werbung beim VfL. Das macht ja keinen Sinn.
Ich habe dir ja gesagt, wir sollten das Sponsoring-Paket kaufen. Dann unser eigenes Geräusch aussuchen.
Was wäre das für eins?
Das müsste ich überlegen. Aber wir müssen das wirklich irgendwann mal kaufen. Machen wir das mal ein?
Könnte neues Goal by Steady werden.
Ja, 699 Euro, die das Sponsoring-Paket von allen kaufen könnten. Wieso nicht?
Nein.
Das kommt wahrscheinlich noch dazu. Das kriegst du für den Fufi wahrscheinlich. Dann kaufen wir das, oder? Wenn der Preis auf den Fufi gefallen ist, kaufen wir das, versprochen.
Wie wichtig ist denn für dich das eigentliche Spiel dann im Start-up? Wechselt das von Ground zu Ground?
Also grundsätzlich finde ich natürlich, oder macht es natürlich schon mehr Spaß, auch ein attraktives Spiel zu beobachten, als jetzt ein richtig spieleres, schlechtes Spiel. Aber es hat jetzt nicht so viel Einfluss darauf, ob es in der Lieblingsverein wird oder nicht, weil das ist ja komplett variabel.
Aber was ich damit meinte ist, konzentrierst du dich dann aufs Spiel? Es sind diese Momente, in denen du eben andere Dinge findest, an denen du dich erfreust. Also bei allen, dass du dann auf Eckbälle hoffst, oder in Dortmund hast du mal 80 Minuten des Spiels laut eurem Buch mit Blick auf eine Betonwand verbracht, weil Dortmund zurück lag gegen Hoffenheim. Das ist auch tatsächlich ein Schicksal, das kann ich auch nachvollziehen.
Vor allem, weil meine Mama ist Dortmund-Fan. Als wir dann quasi losgefahren sind, oder als wir erstmal losgegangen sind, hat sie noch gesagt, bring drei Punkte für den BVB mit. Das hätte ich dann noch nicht erfüllen können. Deswegen konnte ich das dann ja nicht akzeptieren.
Genau, aber sind das dann die Ausnahmen, wo du dich mit solchen Dingen beschäftigst, die mit dem eigentlichen Spiel nichts zu tun haben?
Also es ist nicht so, dass das die Ausnahmen sind. Ich achte schon sehr darauf. Am Anfang habe ich nur darauf geachtet, mittlerweile gucke ich auch das Spiel. Aber im Fokus liegen trotzdem noch solche Skorialitäten.
Und kannst du dich dann an so etwas wie Taktik erfreuen? Denn das ist ja so auch eine analytische Art, Fußball zu schauen. Und es gibt Leute, die mögen das total. Ich gucke ja Fußball inzwischen auch so, habe das aber früher gar nicht gemacht. Deswegen kann ich mich auch noch erinnern, wie es war, einfach nur ein Fußballspiel geguckt zu haben und nicht auf Ketten zu schauen und auf solche Verschiebungen. Ist das nochmal so ein Zugang zu diesem Spiel, der für dich was Besonderes hat?
Damit kenne ich mich auch gar nicht gut genug aus. Bis jetzt habe ich mich damit eigentlich noch nicht so richtig beschäftigt. Ich habe mal was dazu gelesen, aber während ich geguckt habe, habe ich mich damit noch nicht beschäftigt.
Spannend, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das eventuell etwas für dich sein könnte. Die Analysefähigkeit hast du ja auch. Vor allem auch beim taktischen Schauen eines Fußballs muss man sich auch von Emotionen häufig trennen.
Das muss ich gar nicht.
Da hast du dann einen Vorsprung. Dann kannst du ins Rasenfunk-Redaktionsteam kommen.
Aber spielt denn der Fußball mittlerweile eine Rolle oder eine größere Rolle für dich? Du hast ja vorhin gesagt, vor dem ersten Stadionbesuch war Fußball eigentlich überhaupt nicht dein Thema und hat dich gar nicht interessiert. Ist denn so, dass dich der Fußball mehr oder vielleicht auch das Geschehen in der Liga dann so ein bisschen mehr interessiert? Oder geht es tatsächlich immer noch eigentlich hauptsächlich um die Stadionbesuche und um deinen Schema, um deine Auswahl eines Vereins?
Also hauptsächlich geht es um die Stadionbesuche. Wie gesagt, dass es nun Fußball ist und nicht irgendwas anderes. Das war ja Zufall. Aber rückblickend bin ich doch relativ glücklich damit, dass es so gelaufen ist, dass es nun Fußball war, weil die Stadionbesuche selber stehen im Fokus. Weil so außerhalb der Stadionbesuche gucke ich eigentlich im Fernsehen auch nie Fußball. Also eigentlich beschränkt es sich nach wie vor auf die Stadionbesuche. Das ist Interesse daran.
Jetzt wissen wir, die wir hier am Tisch sitzen, aber vielleicht noch nicht alle hören und höre, dass ihr beide euch auch für viele andere Themen inzwischen einsetzt. Deswegen habe ich das auch so anmoderiert. Also ihr äußert euch sehr deutlich gegen Diskriminierung, auch gerade im Netz. Da kann man, denke ich, später nochmal kurz drüber sprechen. Und auch das Thema Klimawandel ist dir, Jason, ganz wichtig. Wenn ich mir jetzt den Fußball mal als Gesamtkonstrukt angucke, da hatte ich vorhin schon so eine Frage in diese Richtung gestellt, dann entwickelt er sich ja auch nicht immer nur zum Guten. Auch zum Beispiel was Dinge angeht wie Umgang mit Klimapolitik, auch was Dinge angeht wie das sich laute Äußern gegen Diskriminierung von Minderheiten. Nimmst du diese Entwicklung im Fußball wahr? Sind die für dich wichtig oder ist das für dich eine völlig losgelöste Welt von diesem Stadion-Erlebnis?
Natürlich gibt es dort Verbindungen zu. Das ist ja eigentlich allgegenwärtig. Aber ich sehe jetzt nicht, dass der Wandel im Fußball stärker ist als im Rest der Gesellschaft. Ja, sogar im Gegenteil, würde ich sagen. Es war schon so, dass in einigen Stadionen auch Diskriminierung erlebt wurde. Aber es fühlt sich dann doch immer sehr eng grenzen und auch zahlenmäßig sehr eng grenzen. Es waren immer doch sehr, sehr wenige Leute, die sehr, sehr vielen Leuten gegenüber standen, die teilweise leider geschwiegen haben. Das könnte man dann irgendwie so verstehen wie Schweigen heißt Legitimation, weil man hat halt nichts aktiv dagegen getan, dass nun deutlich wird, dass das eben nicht die Mehrheit ist dort. Aber es ist ja dennoch erstmal beruhigend, dass man dann doch sieht, dass es dann in einem Stadion mit mehreren Zehntausend Leuten vielleicht 20 Leute sind, die sich dann so in die Richtung äußern. Und da geht es hauptsächlich eigentlich darum, denen nicht quasi die Repräsentation zu überlassen. Aber es sind eigentlich so wenige Leute wirklich, dass man dort jetzt von einem Wandel im Fußball nicht sprechen kann, glaube ich.
Und wenn es jetzt zur Debatte gestanden hätte, mit dem Zug zur WM 2018 nach Russland zu fahren, oder vielleicht dann noch das plakativere Beispiel, Mirko bekommt es irgendwie hin, dass man mit einer sehr attraktiven Zuganreise nach Katar reisen kann und dann sich da eine Fußball-WM anschaut, bei der man ja weiß, dass jetzt im Zuge der Stadionerbauung zum Beispiel viele Wanderarbeiter unter nicht wirklich guten Bedingungen eingesetzt werden. Wäre das dann für dich wichtig bei der Entscheidung, dorthin zu fahren?
Also es kommt darauf an, jetzt im Beispiel Russland würde ich grundsätzlich nicht sagen, nein, ich würde dort gar nicht hinfahren, weil man ja auch einfach, man kann es dann ja auch wirklich einfach so darstellen, wie es dort dann auch war und kann dort, ja kann dort vielleicht auch ein bisschen, oder wenn man dann quasi darüber berichtet, ja auch einfach Aufklärungsarbeit leisten oder auch seine Meinung dazu äußern. Es gab ja tatsächlich mal ein Beispiel davon. Pabsi hat ja tatsächlich mal das Angebot bekommen. Also Katar wäre jetzt schon was anderes, wenn dort wirklich ja teilweise fast schon, geht ja fast schon in die Richtung Sklaven oder Zwangsarbeiter dort, die das Stadion gebaut haben. Ich glaube, da würde ich dann auch eine Grenze ziehen, wo ich sage, nein, da würde ich auch nicht mehr hingehen, nur um dort quasi das Stadion zu besuchen und quasi darüber zu berichten und vielleicht auch Aufklärungsarbeit zu leisten. Ich glaube, da würde ich dann schon auch eine Grenze ziehen, wo ich das dann auch nicht mehr besuchen würde. Russland an sich würde ich, wenn das mit dem Zug geklappt hätte, oder es hätte ja mit dem Zug geklappt, hätte ich das schon gemacht. Aber wir haben dann ja gefragt, nachdem Papst ihr das Angebot bekommen hat, mit der transsiberischen Eisenbahn durch Russland fahren und immer zu den Spielen der deutschen Nationalmannschaft, aber alles mit dem Zug, das klang ja schon verlockend, weil die transsiberische Eisenbahn ist nicht meine Lieblingsstrecke, die Lieblingsstrecke ist die transmongolische, aber die transsiberische Eisenbahn ist natürlich schon, ich glaube, eine der besten Zugstrecken, die es überhaupt gibt, nach der transmongolischen vielleicht. Und daher wäre ich natürlich schon gerne mit damit gefahren, aber ich habe dann ja gefragt, ob die quasi das Motto so war, Russland von seiner schönen Seite zeigen. Und ich konnte das halt irgendwie nicht so richtig interpretieren. Also was bedeutet Russland irgendwie von seiner schönen Seite zeigen? Grundsätzlich bin ich ja auch dafür, dass man nicht immer nur über das Schlechte redet oder über das, was schlecht ist, aber wenn man über Russland Bericht erstattet, dann muss man natürlich dort auch schon irgendwie die Realität, die Verhältnisse darstellen, also Umgang mit Journalisten, Homophobie oder sowas. Und dann habe ich Papsi gefragt, er soll die halt mal fragen, ja was bedeutet Russland von seiner schönen Seite, wie kann man sich zu diesen Themen dort äußern? Und die haben dann gesagt, ja, ihr könnt wirklich dazu äußern, aber das würde dann rausgeschnitten werden, weil es quasi eine unpolitische Dokumentation sein sollte.
Ja, bemerkenswert offen immerhin die Antwort.
Ja, und dann haben wir es dann doch nicht gemacht.
Und wie hat sich dein, Mirko, dein Blick auf den Fußball verändert? Du warst Fußballfan, wir haben dich auch noch so kennengelernt, also Frank und ich, es ist das wir, als du noch in München warst, und du hast jetzt ja auch über acht Jahre hinweg ganz viele Grounds gesehen, viele Dinge gesehen und konntest dich nicht an Jimbo's Autowäsche erfreuen. Du hast aber auch gesagt, in den unteren Ligen gibt es vielleicht andere Möglichkeiten, die Fans zu bekommen, und meine persönliche Wahrnehmung ist, dass der Kommerz auch immer weiter nach unten durchsickert in den Ligen.
Ja, also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass in der vierten Liga nicht irgendwie dort irgendwie alles mit Banden zugekleistert ist und die auf die tollsten Ideen kommen, die Gulaschkanone mittags noch von wem auch immer zu spondern oder so. Ich glaube halt irgendwie schon daran, dass es gar nicht so als komplette Liga, sondern dass es einzelne Vereine geben wird, die dort vielleicht auf den Ebenen Möglichkeiten finden, das zu umgehen. Das ist zumindest vielleicht auch nur eine lose Hoffnung. Insgesamt ist es so, dass ich, wenn ich es vergleiche, als wir losgezogen sind, zumindest für mich am Wochenende das aktuelle Sportstudio oder auch nach Mittags noch mal tatsächlich eine Radiokonferenz oder sowas, was für mich eigentlich zum Samstagsstandard gehörte, wenn es sich beruflich vereinbaren ließ, dass ich dann irgendwie das unterwegs noch hören konnte oder wo auch immer. Ansonsten zumindest die Zusammenfassung immer, dass es zum Standard gehörte, spätestens dann am Samstagabend oder am späten Abend im Sportstudio. Und das hat massiv nachgelassen über die Jahre. Da würde ich jetzt aber auch gar nicht zwingend irgendwie jetzt sagen, oh, die Kommerzialisierung ist schuld, die Kommerzialisierung ist schuld. Das würde ich gar nicht so als den einzigen Grund dort angeben wollen. Aber es war eine Zeit lang so, dass mich tatsächlich dann das nackte Ergebnis meines Vereins, das war dann immer etwas, wo man dann schnell mal geschaut hat oder mal auf den Ticker geguckt hat. Und dadurch, wenn wir dann unterwegs sind, ist dann Rückreise, dann kommst du abends um 24 Uhr aus Aue zurück oder so, dann ist das Sportstudio auch vorbei. Du hast ja die Wiederholung auf Dreiser, da hast du auch keinen Bock mehr, weil du den ganzen Tag unterwegs warst. So hat das nach und nach nachgelassen. Und ich habe es dann erst so gar nicht richtig wahrgenommen, dass ich im TV eigentlich fast gar kein Spiel mehr konsumiere. Das ging dann weiter mit den WMs und EMs oder so. Ich war beim 7 zu 1 Joggen gegen Brasilien. Das ist so das einzige Spiel, wo ich immer Rückblick sage, das war eine ziemlich beschissene Idee. Wo warst du damals? Ich war im Wald. Das hat mich wirklich nicht mehr interessiert. Mir hat das gereicht, was ich gesehen habe, wenn wir so unterwegs waren. Das hat mich auch erfreut, aber mich hat es dann eher genervt. Wobei das vielleicht dann auch so ein bisschen in die Richtung geht, wo du mit dem Rasenfunk dann auch versuchst, das Gegenstück zu bilden. Da ist es vielleicht auch die Form dessen, wie es mir dann serviert wurde, weil mich halt nicht interessiert, was Frau Hummels für einen Kaffee trinkt. Das interessiert mich halt wirklich nicht. Mich hätte dann wirklich noch mehr Infos zum Spiel. Es gab dann auch zwei, drei aktuelle Sportstudio-Gäste, wo ich mich richtig drauf gefreut habe. Wo ich dann gesagt habe, meine Güte, wie kann man denn so banale, wirklich dumme Fragen zum Teil stellen, wenn man die Möglichkeit hat, so einen tollen Gast insgesamt da zu haben. Und so ließ das nach und nach. Und wir haben jetzt im letzten Jahr, im Urlaub zur Weltmeisterschaft, dann die zweite Phase, da haben wir, ich glaube, zwei Spiele gesehen, oder eineinhalb vielleicht. Von den Deutschlandspielen hast du, glaube ich, eins gesehen, da habe ich gar keins gesehen.
Genau, von den Deutschlandspielen habe ich eins gesehen und ich habe England gegen Belgien.
Und sonst zusammen haben wir nur die Schweiz geguckt gegen Serbien, was so ein bisschen familiär bedingt ist, weil meine Frau aus Mazedonien kommt. Und da wir dann ähnlich wie in der Nordkurve dann einfach so ein bisschen jemand anders voll emotioniert erleben dürfen. Aber ansonsten ist das etwas, was massiv nachgelassen hat. Ganz, ganz massiv.
Und wenn ich jetzt ein Fußball-Fan aus einem anderen Land wäre und ich würde dir die Frage stellen, Fußball in Deutschland, wie ist das so?
Was würdest du antworten? Gut, müsste ich gegebenenfalls, wenn ich es ihm so ganz allgemeingültig oder möglichst allgemeingültig versuchen müsste zu beschreiben, wäre es schon etwas schwierig. Es wäre gegebenenfalls etwas interessanter herauszufinden, was ihn am Fußball reizt, um ihm dann gegebenenfalls klar den Tipp zu geben, die erste Liga kannst du dir schenken. Und mir fehlen vielleicht, obwohl wir ja das ein oder andere Mal international unterwegs waren, auch so ein bisschen die Vergleiche. Wir waren zum Beispiel in England noch gar nicht, wo alle mal gesagt haben, wo ich eher glaube, da wird es wahrscheinlich nochmal so on top das werden, was ich hier schon missachte. Die können wir ja dann eben geben. Sodass ich ihm empfehlen würde, entweder in Saarbrücken eine schöne Merguez-Frikadelle zu essen oder mit dem Jason zum VfR Aalen zu fahren, um ein vernünftiges Bild von Deutschland zu bekommen.
Ja, aber ich finde das insofern interessant. Ein bisschen hast du dich jetzt rausgehunden aus der Antwort, weil ihr halt im Vergleich zum Beispiel zu Frank und mir, zu denjenigen gehört, die sehr viele Stadien sehen in Deutschland und die sehr viel vor Ort sind. Und wir sind so Passivkonsumenten. Wir haben nicht die Möglichkeit, so viel zu sehen. Und das heißt, wir bekommen das dann immer nur durch die Brille von Journalisten, von anderen Groundhoppern, von Vereinsvertretern, bekommen wir so ein Bild von der Fußballkultur in Deutschland. Und ich frage mich, wir wissen, dass sie sehr wichtig ist für Deutschland. Also Deutschland ohne seinen Fußball, das wäre wie Deutschland ohne seine Autobahn ohne Tempolimit.
Mit dem Tempolimit von 100 oder so.
Genau, aber es ist für den Deutschen nicht vorstellbar, das wollte ich damit sagen. Also der Fußball ist ganz wichtig. Und gleichzeitig weiß man natürlich so grob, welche Regionen es dann gibt, die wichtig sind. Aber so ein Gefühl für die deutsche Fußballkultur, das ist mir so ein bisschen verloren gegangen, weil ich das Gefühl habe, ich lese sehr gerne die Elfreunde, ich schätze die Autoren der Elfreunde, aber das entwickelt sich für mich gefühlt nicht mehr weiter. Also dieses Bild von Fußballkultur ist für mich einfach das Gleiche, wie als ich vor fünf Jahren Elfreunde gelesen habe. Und deswegen würde mich einfach interessieren, was da so eure Haltung zu ist, weil ihr seid ja nun mal vor Ort und ihr bekommt es eben mit, dass auch beim VfR Ahlen ja ein, ich weiß nicht, wie großer Teil an Zuschauern kommt, der immer da ist und für den der VfR Ahlen das Allerwichtigste ist.
Also man muss dann sicherlich so ein bisschen dahingehend dann auch wieder irgendwo in die verschiedenen Gruppen der die klassische Fanszene, sei es dann der VfR Ahlen, sei es dann Carl Zeiss Jena, sei es dann Wismut Aue oder was auch immer, ist schon etwas, was wir, das ist auch das Einzige, was ich vorab immer so ein bisschen dann auch nochmal recherchiere, wie sind die so auch politisch positioniert, was bedeutet welches Banner, wer steckt da so dahinter, das ist tatsächlich etwas, was ich mir intensiver anschaue. Eigentlich immer nur, um rechtzeitig der Gefahr begegnen zu können, dass wenn Jason sagt, die finde ich aber cool, dass ich da gegebenenfalls nochmal sagen kann, stopp, schau mal, das geht in diese Richtung dort insgesamt.
Das wäre ja aber auch ein Ausschlusskriterium.
Das wäre ja dann auch ein Ausschlusskriterium. Da gibt es halt sehr, sehr positive Beispiele, da gibt es aber auch negative Beispiele. Boah, ich will jetzt nicht wieder 26-mal Fanpost bekommen aus der Ecke. Aber es gibt genügend und die sind auch allseits bekannt. Im Umkehrschluss ist es aber auch so, dass dieses, darf man das diesen Kampf nennen oder so, wenn nicht so diese Diskussion häufig, die man so ganz, ganz häufig hat, wann ist man denn dann eigentlich so Fan vom Fußball oder wann darf man sich Fan nennen? Das ist ja diese Diskussion, die so alle halbe Jahre dann irgendwie aufploppt. Die Bayern-Fans, die gibt es ja sowieso nicht. Das sind ja dann wieder nur die Kunden und das ist ja eine Diskussion, die auch selbst nicht mal…
Das Bielefeld der Fußballkultur bei Bayern-Fans.
Genau, also da gibt es ja so ganz viele und die ganz echten, das sind halt nur sowieso die, die auf der Süd in Dortmund stehen. Und so dieses ganze Zinnober, das ist glaube ich etwas dessen, wo ich am meisten dazu gelernt habe, dass es ganz sicher nicht davon abhängig ist, welche Klassifizierung du als Fan hast, dass die weder von deinem Sitzplatz abhängig ist, noch von deiner Positionierung im Stadion insgesamt. Also da habe ich in Kurven schon Leute Candy Crush spielen sehen und ich habe auch in der Haupttribüne Leute zittern sehen und mitfiebern sehen, wo ich gedacht habe, wenn du den jetzt von der Seite anstippst, dann fällt der einfach tot um. Der ist so im Tunnel. Da habe ich in beide Richtungen beides erlebt, sodass du natürlich vielleicht in der Kurve eher die einen findest und auf der Haupttribüne vielleicht auch mal den, der ganz gemütlich fast einschlafend das Spiel an sich vorüberziehen lässt oder auch den klassischen Viertelstunde-Früher-Geher oder was auch immer. Aber das ist auch etwas, wer bin ich anderen Leuten fortzuschreiben, wie sie ihren Fußball konsumieren sollen, dürfen, müssen etc. Also das ist etwas, ich denke, das ist so diese Bandbreite der Möglichkeiten. Du kannst hingehen und kannst dich dort völlig verausgaben. In Bremen bei der Lesung habe ich mit jemandem von einem Werder-Fanclub gesprochen, die halt über diese Green-White-Wonderwall-Geschichte, wenn die dann dort springen, 30, 40, für die war dieses auch körperlich aktiv sein etwas, was bei mir bisher etwas war. Ich bin noch nicht bescheuert, ich gehe noch nicht ins Stadion, dann rammele ich den ganzen Tag beruflich durch die Gegend und springe dann noch da wie ein Idiot durch die Gegend. Also unsere körperlichen Aktivitäten im Stadion – ich doch einmal Party sagen, da mussten wir. Aber ansonsten sind wir dort immer eher so die Genussmenschen. Und die Form des Genusses, da gibt es ganz, ganz, ganz viele verschiedene Ansätze, die alle legitim sind, alle vollkommen in Ordnung sind, aber es ist halt trotzdem amüsant, das dann auch zuzuschauen oder zuzuhören, wie auf der Haupttribüne die Leute motzen, dass die Kurve heute zu wenig Stimmung macht, oder in der Kurve die Leute motzen, dass die Haupttribüne nicht aufsteht, oder das gehört halt vielleicht irgendwie auch mit dazu, gegebenenfalls. Aber völlig wertfrei sehe ich das mittlerweile.
Über diese unterschiedliche Wahrnehmung von Fußball und von Fan-Dasein?
Also grundsätzlich gibt es ja leider keine allgemeine Definition von Fan. Deswegen würde ich sagen, dass die einzige Definition, die man eigentlich dort nehmen kann, jeder, der sich als Fan bezeichnet, ist auch ein Fan, weil man es ja nicht widerlegen kann. Jeder hat ja auch die eigene Definition von Fan, und es gibt ja irgendwie keine objektiven Möglichkeiten, das zu vergleichen oder auf zwei verschiedene Ebenen oder auf zwei verschiedene Stufen zu stellen. Sie gibt es ja nicht, weil es einfach keine allgemeine Definition gibt. Deswegen kann man eigentlich auch niemandem absprechen, Fan zu sein, wenn er sagt, er ist Fan, weil es da gar nicht eindeutig definiert ist, was Fan ist.
Das finde ich sehr faszinierend, aber auch sehr schlüssig, dass jemand, der sein eigenes Fan da sein nach klaren Kriterien bestimmt, dann aber zugesteht, dass jeder Fan sein kann, weil es die Definition nicht gibt. Also es ist in sich total schlüssig, hätte ich aber gar nicht so erwartet, weil ich noch nicht fertig drüber nachgedacht hatte.
Lass uns doch mal zurückkommen auf das Thema Blog, bzw. eigentlich in der Verlängerung dazu würde ich fast sagen, das Thema Buch. Wie kam es denn dazu, dass ihr irgendwann zum eigenen Buch kam? Wie ist das Projekt entstanden? Die Aufmerksamkeit, würde ich mal sagen, ist ja hauptsächlich durchs Blog entstanden, oder?
Ja, also eigentlich ist so ein bisschen fast der Max schuld, würde ich sagen. Und wenn man es ganz weit denkt, ist es nicht nur ein bisschen, sondern es ist tatsächlich so. Also wenn man wirklich ganz, ganz weit zurückspint, es hat ein bisschen gedauert, um es komplett auch so rückwirkend nachvollziehen zu können, dann ist Max in nicht geringem Teil dafür verantwortlich, dass es Wochenendrebellen als Buch gibt. Denn er hat mich jemandem vorgestellt, beim damaligen TP Muck, über den es einen Artikel im Nido-Magazin entstanden. Dieser Artikel ist gelandet bei den Herrschaften von einem großen deutschen Fußball-Kultur-Magazin, welches heute auch schon zur Sprache kam. Die hatten uns mal angeschrieben und haben gesagt, wir könnten uns vorstellen, mal was mit euch zu machen. Wie sieht es denn da aus? Können wir euch mal begleiten? Oder wie könnte das aussehen? Das war aber noch in der Phase, in der wir gesagt haben, ich bin beruflich so eng, dass ich meistens Donnerstags oder Freitags erst weiß, welches Spiel samstags oder sonntags in Frage kommt. Das ist natürlich für jemanden, der dann irgendwie planen muss in irgendeiner Art und Weise, der vielleicht auch am Wochenende den Anspruch hat, ich will halt nicht nur mit den Wochenend-Rebellen ein Spiel sehen, sondern ich muss auch noch so zwei, drei andere Sachen erledigen, hat das immer nicht so gepasst. Sodass über diesen Kontakt wiederum der Kontakt entstanden ist zu einer Dame, zu der Frau Schmitz, die beauftragt war, einen neuen Verlag oder das Programm für einen neuen Verlag, den Benevento-Verlag, und ja, um das auch gleich vorweg zu nehmen, das ist ein Tochterverlag der Red Bull Media AG insgesamt, was mir damals auch das Angebot kam, Ende 2013, Anfang 2014, würde ich sagen, vollkommen bewusst war. Und da kam dann eine Mail quasi dann rein und sagt, ja, guten Tag Herr von Ljudatschenka, ich habe jetzt in Ihrem Blog ein bisschen gelesen und ich will es kurz machen, ich hätte das gern als Buch, ob ich mir das vorstellen könnte. Dann habe ich erstmal zurückgeschrieben, nee, kann ich mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen, weil ich überhaupt gar keine Vorstellung hatte, wie das zeitlich funktionieren sollte.
Wenn du mir damals gesagt hättest, dass du einen Buchvorschlag abgelehnt hättest.
Ja, wärst du sauer gewesen.
Das Wort sauer wäre eine Untertreibung, ein Ortenismus für das, was da passiert wäre.
Jedenfalls sind wir dann so verblieben, dass wir gesagt haben, wir können uns gerne einfach mal unverbindlich treffen. Die Dame war super angenehm, wir haben kurz telefoniert, sagte dann Mensch, ich komme hin, wo sie wollen, sagen sie mir wann und wie und wo, dann bin ich da und dann unterhalten wir uns einfach mal. Und dann haben wir uns irgendwie ein paar Wochen später hier in München getroffen und ich hatte mich dahingehend gut vorbereitet mit meiner großen Liste, was alles dagegen spricht, warum ich kein Buch schreiben kann. Und dann hat sie halt noch mal so ein bisschen geschildert und das noch mal so ein bisschen rief passieren lassen, wie so der Kontakt entstanden ist, was so ihre Herangehensweise an das Programm ist. Und dann habe ich so meine Punkte geschildert und habe gesagt, naja, ich bin kein gelernter Autor und wenn man sich mit meinem Blog länger als fünf Minuten auseinandersetzt, dann sieht man, dass vielleicht auch Zeichensetzungen und Grammatik und Co. nicht nur etwas ist, wo ich nicht sonderlich gut drinne bin, sondern was mich auch gar nicht interessiert. Also wenn ich das dann damals so im Zug schnell weggerotzt hab, dann ist das in diesem Blog rein. Und dann war mein Anspruch, man muss verstehen können, was da drinne steht. Der Rest war mir völlig egal. Und ich konnte mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen, mich irgendwie mühselig mit einem Text nochmal im Nachgang auseinanderzusetzen, insbesondere wenn der dann so sonderlich groß ist. Das war so mein erster Punkt. Dazu kam dann noch so, sich in Normen und in Normformate einzwängen zu lassen, dass du das jetzt nicht in Comic Sans 23.5 schreiben kannst, in deiner Wörterteile, sondern dass das so und so. Das waren alles Dinge, wo ich gesagt habe, ne, und dann hat ich das gesagt. Also das ist so erstmal das Hauptpaket. Und da dachte ich, okay, da können sie einen Haken dran machen. Sie können mir den Text einsprechen, sie können ihn mir handschriftlich schicken, sie können ihn mir zufaxen, sie können ihn mir mailen, das ist mir völlig egal. Sie müssen es nur selber schreiben. Das ist der Anspruch, den wir haben. Alles andere kriegen wir irgendwie geregelt. Und ich habe gesagt, okay, das war schon etwas, was mir klar war, als ich mich vorher so ein bisschen nach der Anfrage mit dem Thema Buch beschäftigt habe, dass das schon ungewöhnlich ist. Und ich habe dann gesagt, na ja, und ich brauche definitiv die Möglichkeit, das gegebenenfalls unter einem Pseudonym veröffentlichen zu können, auch wenn das vielleicht für sie total irre klingt, aber wir sind im Blog anonym unterwegs und das möchten wir vielleicht auch noch ein Weilchen bleiben. Sie sagt, okay, das ist das kleinste Problem, das können wir auch machen. Und ich habe dann gesagt, na ja, und auch wenn es bei der Geschichte natürlich für den Verkauf förderlich ist, möchte ich, dass auf dem Titel das Wort Autismus nicht vorkommt. Oder autistisch oder irgend sowas in der Richtung. Das möchte ich nicht. Und wenn es mit Bildern von uns, dann dürfen müssen das Bilder sein, auf denen wir nicht zu erkennen sind. Und egal was ich gesagt habe, sie hat bei allem gesagt, kriegen wir hin, kriegen wir hin, kriegen wir hin, kriegen wir hin. Dann habe ich gesagt, okay, dann gibt es eigentlich nur noch den letzten Punkt. Ich bin zeitlich, beruflich extrem eingespannt. Ich bin jetzt seit 20 Jahren beim selben Arbeitgeber, aber das war dann so in einer Phase. Ich habe im Regelfall so 300 Stunden im Monat gearbeitet. Das war eigentlich das normale Paket, was man so… Das war eigentlich so das normale Paket. Und es war halt auch die langen Zugfahrten, die ich immer mal phasenweise… Man sieht das, wenn man noch so die Blogposts sieht, wann und wie die veröffentlicht sind. Dann sieht man, dass das zum Teil manchmal zwischendurch auch so… Da ist dann mal wieder acht Wochen gar nichts und komplette Ruhe. Das sind meistens die Phasen, wo wir irgendwie einen Umbau oder neue… Gibt es nicht mehr so häufig.
Gar nicht mehr. Podcasten ja eigentlich.
Ach so, dann ist gegebenenfalls Lichtern Podcast an. Aber da war dann gar keine Zeit, irgendwas zu schreiben oder zu veröffentlichen, weil selbst die Zugzeit dann einfach mit dem normalen Büroarbeiten eigentlich genutzt werden musste. Und so hatte ich ihr dann damals gesagt, ich wüsste gar nicht, wie ich das zeitlich machen sollte. Also müssten sie mir minimum zwei Jahre Zeit einräumen für ein Buch, was erstmal völlig irrsinnig ist, weil das Material war ja da. Sie hat gesagt, sie brauchen eigentlich nur die Blogposts nehmen und dann so ein bisschen zusammen schreiben. Und ich habe dann gesagt, ich brauche minimum zwei Jahre Zeit. Und sie hat gesagt, sie kriegen Vertrag, sie tragen den Zeitraum an, wann sie das Manuskript abgeben. Da würde ich sie bitten, planen sie da lieber ein bisschen mehr an, als ein bisschen weniger. Aber dann sind sie nicht im ersten Programm oder im zweiten Programm, sondern sind sie halt im dritten Programm. Das ist unproblematisch. Und dann war der letzte Punkt, dass ich gesagt habe, na ja, und was halt noch dazu kommt, ich hocke mich dann dahin, sage meiner Frau, hör mal zu, ich habe jetzt noch weniger Zeit, weil ich jetzt nachts noch Bücher schreibe. Und dann am Ende habe ich ein Buch in der Hand und kann sagen, toll, wir haben ein Buch ausgebracht. Und dann verkauft sich das dreimal und man kriegt als Auto irgendwie so 12% im Schnitt. Das sind dann irgendwie so zwei Euro pro Buch, sage ich mal, so grob gesagt. Das heißt, du hast dann irgendwie da sehr viel Arbeit reingesteckt und dann bleiben da 6, 50 Euro hingewohnt und du sagst, nee, das geht auch nicht.
Das geht schon. Ich hätte Geld dafür bezahlt.
Gut, dass du die Verhandlung nicht gefilmt hast.
Sie haben dann ein unglaublich attraktives Angebot unterbreitet, wo ich gesagt habe, okay, das wäre schon etwas, was gegebenenfalls einen Aufwand rechtfertigt, weil ich dann im Anschluss vielleicht sagen kann, hey, es verschafft mir die Luft, gegebenenfalls meine berufliche Situation mal in Ruhe zu überdenken und gegebenenfalls wirklich auch mal in das Risiko eines Jobwechsels. Ich war in einer Phase, wo ich in einem Rad drin war, wo einen Jobwechsel gar nicht zu denken war, weil ich gar nicht gewusst hätte, wann sollst du eine Bewerbung schreiben, oder wenn jemand anruft und sagt, Entschuldigung, ich will Sie zum Vorstellungsgespräch haben, ich hätte gar nicht gewusst, wann ich dahin sollte, weil es so eng getaktet war.
Ich hätte es aber nicht gut gefunden, wenn der Job gewechselt ist.
Weiß ich, weiß ich. Aber es war halt trotzdem etwas, wo ich die einzige Ausflucht zu dem Zeitpunkt gesehen habe. Und das war halt etwas, wo ich dann auch mit meiner Frau gesprochen habe, gesagt habe, naja, es würde uns schon mal den Puffer verschaffen, gegebenenfalls, wenn ich keinen fließenden Wechsel hinkriege, auch einfach mal zwei Monate zu überbrücken, ohne dass wir dort in Panik geraten müssen. Und das waren dann so auf ganz, ganz vielen Ebenen die Situation, wo ich gesagt habe, okay, der Aufwand wird dann im Normalfall vielleicht auch geringer sein, weil ja schon relativ viel Material da ist. Also die hatten jetzt nicht die Erwartungshaltung, dass ich alles komplett neu schreibe. Sodass ich gesagt habe, okay, dann ich mach mir da mal Gedanken zu und meld mich dann und hatte ihm dann gute vier bis sechs Wochen später so ganz grob mal so geschrieben, wie das so sein sollte. Er hat da auch mit Jason in der Zwischenzeit gesprochen und er sagte dann halt nur wie immer, da muss ich aber auch dabei sein. Sodass die einzige Bedingung, die dann zusätzlich dazu kam, dass Jason mindestens einen Kapitel bekommt. Und später hat er dann noch vorgeschlagen, naja, also nur den Einstieg ist ein bisschen wenig, dann möchte ich eigentlich das Ende noch. Ein Nachwort ist uns nichts eingefallen. Jetzt gibt es noch ein Nachwort für die Taschenbuchversion. Aber so, dass er dann noch das Glossar beigesteuert hat. Und das waren dann alles Dinge, wo ich dann gesagt habe, wenn ich jetzt das gesamte Paket nehme, und quasi, so wie Jason macht ja gedanklich immer Pro- und Kontralisten, dann standen da echt eine Menge Seiten auf der Pro-Seite. Und auf der Kontra-Seite stand halt, scheiße, das ist Red Bull. Das war definitiv schon so. Wobei ich die 2013 – ich sehe die heute aus zwei Bereichen – sehr, sehr problematisch. 2013 habe ich sie eigentlich aus dem – die machen mir meinen Fußball kaputt – Blickwinkel gesehen. Den ich heute für den deutlichen, also auch für den problematischen, aber im Gesamtpaket für den deutlich oder nicht so problematischen Bereich handele, wenn man insgesamt so dieses Medienkonstrukt sieht. Das war etwas, wo mich damals wenig bis gar nicht mit beschäftigt habe. Das war so die Geschichte zum Buch. Und letztendlich war es wie bei allen anderen Medienkontakten im Anschluss auch. Also wir haben auch mit einer großen Zeitung mit vier Buchstaben was gemacht, was ich vorher ausgeschlossen hätte, weil der Kontakt sehr sehr freundlich, souverän, Zusagen, die ich oder um die ich gebeten habe, wurden gemacht und dann eingehalten. Während es auch andere Medien wiederum gab, wo ich gerne was gemacht hätte, wo es nicht gepasst hatte. Und ähnlich war es dann dort, dass dort einfach der Kontakt zu Frau Schmitz, die wirklich so als Abschlussworte sagte von Gita Czenka, sie können machen, was sie wollen. Es ist wirklich komplett okay, sie müssten es nur schreiben, um alles andere kümmere ich mich. Und Frau Schmitz hat dann sechs Monate später den Verlag verlassen. Dann ging eigentlich, ich will nicht sagen die Schose los oder so, aber ich hatte dann den nächsten Ansprechkartner.
Er wollte die Geschichte beenden, indem er mich zum Bayern-Fan macht.
Er wollte ein Happy End?
Er hat als erstes gefragt, ob das Buch schon fertig geschrieben ist. Da habe ich gesagt, nein. Dann würde er sich jetzt noch mal in die Geschichte einlesen. Dann kommen sie einfach mal in die Allianz Arena und ich bereite das alles vor. Dann haben wir auch ein schönes Ende. Da war das Gute in Anführungszeichen, der war auch nur sechs Monate da oder vier Monate oder so. Dann kam die nächste, die uns betreut hat. Das war dann ein unspektakulärer Kontakt. Ich habe einen Kapitel hingeschickt. Sie hat bei zwei, drei Sachen gesagt, das finde ich nicht so gut, dann habe ich das angepasst. Aber so dieses wirklich richtig gute Gefühl, sich bei der Person, die einen betreut, ich fühle mich dort gut aufgehoben. Das ist so wie heute. Heute ist ein Termin, wo ich mich nicht vorbereite. Wo ich jetzt nicht sage, jetzt muss ich erst mal gucken, was ist dieser Max für einer? Was stellt der für hinterhältige Fragen? Was ist mit diesem Helmi? Was hat es mit dem Frank auf sich?
Wir planen ja die Sendung auf seit zwei Jahren.
Das ist bei vielen anderen Medienterminen etwas, wo du natürlich erst mal 23 Eventualitäten in alle Richtungen abklopft. Wo ich mich dann aber immer in einem persönlichen Gespräch gegebenenfalls noch mal sage, das ist so der letzte ausschlaggebende Punkt. Und da würde ich, wenn ich jetzt die Zeit zurückdrehen könnte, würde ich sagen, hätte es das Buch wahrscheinlich dann aber auch gar nicht gegeben. Weil darauf zu warten, dass ich irgendwann mit Manuskripten von Verlag zu Verlag tingel, das wäre nicht geschehen. Doch, wär's. Du hättest es vielleicht gemacht.
Die Idee hätte ja vielleicht auch gar nicht existiert, oder? Kam die nicht erst mit der Anfrage von Frau Schmitz?
Die Planung eines Buches gab es eigentlich nicht.
Aber jetzt, zu diesem Zeitpunkt, hätte es eigentlich so oder so ein Buch gegeben. Da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher.
Das kann sein, aber es wäre dann vielleicht eins gewesen, was du geschrieben hättest und ich hätte das Vorwort geschrieben.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Also da gibt es so Dinge, wo ich im Rückblick sage, hm…
Aber wieso hat der erste Verlag mich eigentlich noch nicht als Autor aufgeführt, sondern als erste, zweite?
Weil wir das damals nicht als Bedingung aufgeführt haben.
Wieso nicht?
Weil da haben wir nicht dran gedacht. Da haben wir nicht dran gedacht. Im Taschenbuch stehe ich Gott sei Dank halt das Auto drauf. Die Taschenbuchversion haben wir dann nicht mehr im Benevento Verlag, sondern hier im Goldman Verlag. Das hat uns wirklich nochmal gefreut. Und mit denen hatten wir jetzt nochmal drei oder vier Gespräche, die dann gesagt hatten, hey, wie sieht es aus, jetzt das Cover doch nochmal anzupassen von vorne? Ist das eine Option? Ja, das sehen wir heute deutlich unproblematischer.
Das hat sich durch dich erledigt, durch deine Ignoranz gegenüber Fakten. Also, dass wir heute nicht mehr, oder dass da auf dem neuen Buch kein Zeug mehr steht und wir von vorne zu sehen sind, dass wir das nicht mehr anonym machen, das hat etwas mit Papsis Ignoranz gegenüber Fakten zu tun.
Jetzt musst du dich beichten. Ich kann das beichten, aber eigentlich ist es schöner, wenn du es selber erzählst, glaube ich.
Am besten ist es, wenn du es erzählst, du musst ja beichten. Okay, du willst diese Situation der Demütigung noch ein bisschen auf die Spitze tragen.
Wir haben Abgabetermin für das Maler-Skript gehabt im Mai 2017. Bis zu dem Zeitpunkt war es eigentlich immer noch etwas, dass wir im Blog weiterhin Martin und JJ waren. Das Impressum immer noch, wie seit vielen Jahren, einem wechselnd guten Kumpels gehört. Einmal der Gerhard aus Hamburg, der uns da immer wieder unterstützt hat, aber auch der Martin aus Essen, der uns da immer wieder geholfen hat. Wir haben dann lange überlegt, dass ich gesagt habe, eigentlich war es in meinem Ansatz immer, dass ich gesagt habe, das, was ich dort im Blog niedergeschrieben habe, sind schon recht intime Details aus der Kinderzeit. Man möge mir den Ausdruck verzeihen.
War aber keine Kinderzeit.
Aus deiner Jugendzeit.
War aber auch nicht die Jugendzeit.
Was denn?
Das war ganz normal erwachsenen Zeit.
Okay. Aus deiner sechsjährigen Erwachsenenzeit herauszuschildern, wo ich gesagt habe, wenn der 20 ist, haut er mir das vielleicht um die Ohren.
Das war eine sehr, sehr naive Vorstellung.
Wenn der Jason von Jutta Czenka mit dem Wochenendrebell verbunden ist. Das heißt, mein Ansatz war eigentlich, das sehr, sehr lange zu trennen, auch sehr, sehr rigoros zu trennen.
Aber deine Prognosen gingen von…
Ich habe gedacht, mit 16, 17, 18 vielleicht.
Was für eine Unsinn.
Er hat halt mit 10 schon immer dann auch gelesen und hat gesagt, nö, also ich habe versucht, ihm das zu erklären. Und er hat dann immer gesagt, das ist unproblematisch, das, was da steht, stimmt ja auch. Wo ich sagte, na gut, du kannst dich ja später nicht darauf berufen, dass dein 10-jähriger Sohn gesagt hat, das ist in Ordnung. Das ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Aber als das Freirecht auf Selbstbestimmung eingeführt wurde.
Und dann kam eigentlich der Knackpunkt, dass wir gemerkt haben, so dieses Regelwerk, das, was Jason mit an Regeln hilft, führen wir zu Hause auch ein, hat er vorgeschlagen, im Rahmen einer Familienvereinbarung. Das erste Gesetz war halt das Freirecht auf Selbstbestimmung, was bedeutet, alles, was wirklich nur ihn selbst betrifft, darf er auch zu 100 Prozent alleine entscheiden. Das heißt, wenn ich nachher hier gehe und er sagt, ich will mit dem Max gerne noch Horrorfilme gucken bis morgen früh um fünf, dann kann er das grundsätzlich erstmal tun. Dann muss der Max noch zustimmen, weil das betrifft ja auch den Max, nicht nur den Jason. Aber grundsätzlich dürfte ich nicht sagen, also Jason, hör mal zu, der Film ist ab 18, das möchte ich nicht, dass du den guckst. Und ähnlich ist es halt gewesen in dem Fall, dass er immer wieder gesagt hat, ne, das ist in Ordnung, wir können im Blog oder als es dann später auch um die Buchdiskussion ging, und die zog sich durch die frühe Anfrage ja sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr lang, hat er immer gesagt, ne, wir können das unter dem richtigen Namen machen, das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Und ich war immer so ein bisschen verunsichert, meine Frau stand da auch so 50-50. Und dann kam halt die Information, dass wir nominiert sind für den Grimme Online Award. Die kamen dann, ich weiß gar nicht, irgendwie einen Monat vor Abgabe des Manuskripts oder so. Und dann habe ich das Jason dann gesagt, weil ich gesagt habe, Mensch, das ist eine tolle Veranstaltung in Köln, da können wir dann mal zusammen hinfahren, wenn du möchtest. Und er sagte, ja, okay, wie machen wir das denn mit der Siegerrede, wer hält die denn dann und so weiter? Und ich sagte, ho, ho, ho, Jason, das hast du falsch verstanden. Der WDR ist dort nominiert mit einer sehr speziellen 3D-Reportage über den Kölner Dom, wo man sich online bis in die letzten Details des Domes zoomen kann. Arte war nominiert mit einer sehr aufwendigen Doku über die Meeresverschmutzung mit Plastikmüll. Also es waren schon finanzsträchtige Kaliber dabei.
Ja, das war einfach – das meine ich jetzt mit Faktenignoranz – es sprach absolut alles, restlos alles dafür, dass wir das gewinnen werden.
Das war doch ein Jurypreis, oder?
Das war ein Jurypreis.
Wie die Jury berät, das weißt du.
Ja, aber es sprach einfach alles dafür, wenn man sich das mal so angesehen hat. Es wäre wirklich sehr töricht gewesen, wenn es anders gelaufen wäre. Und Papsi wollte es nicht mehr haben.
Also ich habe das in alle Richtungen. Ich hatte dann hinsichtlich Jury, war mir klar. Es gibt zwar dann auch einen Publikumspreis, aber wenn du dann irgendwie mit – wir waren mit den Datteljägern von Funk oder so – dann irgendwie mal 1, 5 Millionen YouTube-Abonnenten. Da weißt du dann halt auch, ok, da brauchst du jetzt nicht irgendwie deine 2000 Facebook-Fans mobilisieren oder irgendwie so was für so ein Online-Boating. Und das habe ich halt sehr, sehr lange geschoben, geschoben, geschoben, geschoben. Und als wir dann dort saßen auf der Bühne und dann das, was man im Intro quasi gehört – Ich habe die Dankesrede übrigens geschrieben, aber ohne Danke. Ja, natürlich.
Ich habe eigentlich nur eine – oder meine Rede, die eigentlich die Dankesrede war, war eigentlich nur eine Beweihräucherung von mir selbst, in der ich erkläre, wie verdient das alles ist jetzt.
Hast du das damals auch schon so gesehen? Das ist mir auch schon häufiger aufgefallen, auch bei euch im Podcast, dass du schon in der Lage bist, quasi den Außenblick auf Jason – da liegst du manchmal, glaube ich, schon relativ nah bei dem, wie es dann auch tatsächlich ist. Wusstest du es damals auch schon, als du es so formuliert hast?
Aber quasi das Ende der Rede war dann eine Beschwerde, und zwar, dass sie in der falschen Kategorie eigentlich nominiert sind und in der falschen Kategorie gewonnen haben.
Ja, denn wir waren in Kultur und Unterhaltung nominiert, und er hätte eigentlich viel lieber den Grimma Online Award in Bildung und Wissen gewonnen. Ja, und da war quasi dann die Entscheidung gefallen, oder es wurden uns viele Entscheidungen abgenommen, weil wir halt wussten, ok, jetzt stehst du hier, also wir hatten dann noch 45 Sekunden Zeit.
Nein, in dem Moment, wo das erst mal war, es ging ja zuerst so, dass ich eigentlich den ganzen Abend darauf gebraucht habe, dass wir jetzt eigentlich noch zumindest irgendwie eine halbe Stunde Zeit haben, um zu verbrechen, wie wir das dann auf der Bühne machen. Aber ich habe es ja immer wieder gesagt, oder nein, das müssen wir jetzt nicht diskutieren. Und als es dann, oder als es dann, es war dann halt mir eigentlich sofort klar, sobald es dann quasi begann, dass die Leute jetzt auf die Bühne geholt werden, war mir eigentlich klar, ok, es war wirklich 100% klar, es war gar kein Zweifel mehr. Wir müssen gleich dort hochgehen, aber alle anderen tun irgendwie so, als wäre es, oder als hätten wir jetzt keine Chance, das gleich hochzugehen. Ich war mir gar nicht sicher, ob es jetzt irgendwie so gespielte Bescheidenheit ist, oder ob die jetzt wirklich geglaubt haben, dass wir gleich nicht gewinnen. Und dann, ja, es war eigentlich so richtig furchtbar, weil man selber wusste es halt die ganze Zeit, aber irgendwie die anderen haben so getan, als wäre es jetzt nicht selbstverständlich.
Also es war halt ein, ich glaube, einer der skurrilsten Momente in meinem Leben, wenn du da so sitzt so, und ich war eigentlich hauptsächlich mal darauf konzentriert, wie gehst du gleich mit der Enttäuschung deines Sohnes um?
Und ich war damit konzentriert, was tust du wohl gleich, wenn die Nachricht kommt, dass wir gewinnen?
Ja, und dann waren halt auch eigentlich, war unsere Kategorie schon Haken dran, und die Moderatorin Janine Mikaelsen sagte dann, Mensch Oliver, was machst du hier noch auf der Bühne? Was ist los? Und er sagte, naja, wir haben hier in dieser Kategorie einen weiteren Gewinner. Und dann guckte er schon so an der Seite, so nach dem Motto, siehste? Und als dann die Durchsage kam, sah er mich wirklich so ganz vorwurfsvoll an und sagte, ich hab's dir die ganze Zeit gesagt, ich versteh's nicht, ich versteh's nicht.
Und dann kam gerade die Kamera so auf.
Und dann schwenkt er aber auch schon die Kamera um.
Und Papsi war so ganz panisch, und man hat dann quasi mich gar nicht gesehen, sondern nur er, der sich vorgebeugt hat, und so richtig panisch quasi. Er hat gesagt, ja, was machen wir jetzt, was machen wir jetzt? Und ich hab gesagt, du glaubst nicht ernsthaft, dass ich das jetzt mit dir diskutiere, oder?
Ja, und dann ist er aufgestanden und auf die Bühne gegangen. Und das war halt der Moment, wo dann zumindest klar war, okay, diese Verbindung von Wochenendrebell zu Klarname wird zumindest jetzt im Netz etwas sein, was relativ unmissverständlich verbunden ist. Und mit dem Gesicht noch dazu. Sodass uns dort diese, dank meiner, wie hast du es genannt?
Ignoranz gegenüber Fakten.
Meiner Ignoranz gegenüber Fakten hatte sich das Problem dann quasi mehr oder weniger von selbst gelöst. Ja, wahrscheinlich. Wahrscheinlich wäre es sowieso in die Richtung gegangen.
Ich glaube, du hast irgendwie oft keine klare Position zu etwas. Findest du? Da warst du ja auch immer irgendwie so, du warst so 50-50, Mami war so 50-50, und wenn ich nicht da gewesen wäre, dann wäre es wahrscheinlich immer so weitergegangen.
Das siehst du falsch. Es gibt eine zweite Veranstaltung, da kann der Max dann sogar fantastisch sich das vorstellen, weil auf der Veranstaltung waren wir zusammen. Das war letztes Jahr die Verleihung des Deutschen Fußballkulturpreises, wo wir mit dem Buch nominiert waren, mit der umgekehrten Situation, dass wir quasi vorher schon beim Anreisen wussten, wir haben nicht gewonnen. Das heißt, die ganze Diskussion… Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du da bist. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du da bist. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du da bist. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du da bist. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du da bist. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du da bist. Das glaube ich nicht, das kann nicht sein, die können sich nicht so irren. Und dann wollte er wissen, wer alles in der Jury sitzt. Und Mailadressen haben. Wo ich hab schon schwitzend gesessen und hab gedacht, oh mein Gott. Das wird...
Ich wollte nur die Mailadressen, nicht die richtigen Adressen.
Aber vielleicht ist halt auch in so einer Jury manchmal eine Ignoranz von Fakten vorhanden. Oder auch einfach ein anderer Geschmack.
Ein anderer Geschmack, das gilt nicht. Wenn, dann ist eine Ignoranz von Fakten.
Das war dann für mich – und so war es eigentlich beim Grimme Online Award auch – für mich ist dann immer hauptsächlich, wie bekomme ich es jetzt geregelt, dass ich ihm einen Rahmen gebe, wo er damit so umgehen kann, wie er es für richtig hält einerseits, für vielleicht aber auch für die Umgebung nicht irgendwie die gesamte Veranstaltung versaut.
Habe überlegt, was ich mache.
Hassplakate, Buchrufen, also jetzt bei der Kulturstiftung, wo du es schon wusstest.
Ja, also Hassplakate, Buchrufen, aufstehen und so machen oder – also Daumen nach unten zeigen. Ja, genau. Oder wirklich ein Bühnensturm. Aber Bühnensturm war ganz hinten und das Wahrscheinlichste war eigentlich, dass ich nur Buch rufe. Ich habe mich dann entschieden für oder vor Ort habe ich mich dafür entschieden, während quasi oder nach dem Applaus quasi, wenn er eigentlich anfangen wollte, quasi laudatet zu halten, dann aufzustehen, Daumen nach unten zu machen und ganz laut Buh und Fui zu schreien. Und so habe ich dann auch gemacht.
Und ich durfte ihn halten. Hab damit natürlich auch wieder ein wenig gegen gesetzliche Regeln verstanden. Aber es ist halt etwas, wo das Umfeld ja wenig Verständnis für hat dann insgesamt. Das ist ja etwas, was uns ganz, ganz früher sehr, sehr häufig in Straßenbahnen, beim Arzt, beim Supermarkt etc. passiert ist. Dann sitzen da fünf Leute um dich herum, dann lernst du damit umzugehen. Aber so eine Veranstaltung ist dann halt schon noch mal eine andere Hausnummer. Das ist halt nicht der Supermarkt um die Ecke oder so, sondern das war halt schon was, schon was anderes. Und das ist dann schon, weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe dir das doch vorher gesagt, dass ich das mache.
Ja, es ist aber dann trotzdem etwas, wo ich eigentlich immer so ein bisschen als letzte Hoffnung damit habe, dass die Hemmschwelle, wenn es dann da so drinnen ist und er sieht dann so, dass die dann so hoch ist, dass es nicht funktioniert. Und wir hatten dann ja das große Glück, das wussten wir ja so gar nicht, dass Ludger Schulte uns dann ja in seiner Laudatio zum Buch am Anfang erwähnte, was ihn sofort besänftigt. Ich habe ihm dann eine Woche später eine Mail geschrieben, wirklich so eine riesen Mail, und mich bei ihm bedankt, A, für die lieben Worte, und B, weil ich ihm einfach erklären wollte, wie enorm wichtig diese Worte waren, wie enorm wichtig, dass er sich überhaupt nicht vorstellen kann, was das auch für einen Felsklotz war, der von mir, als er das dann gehört hat, wurde er sofort ruhig und als dann lobende Wort, das war für ihn schon, dann war das auch okay, dann war das Thema durch und wir hatten dann einen schönen Abend und alles war fein.
Aber hast du ernsthaft gesagt, ich mache das dann doch nicht mit Boo und Foy?
Ja zumindest habe ich gedacht, dass das vielleicht irgendwie etwas ist, was man im Applaus dann mal untergeht.
Ich habe ja extra gemacht, damit der Applaus vorbei war.
Oder dass eine Reaktion von jemand, der neben dir sitzt, gegebenenfalls dich dann auch wieder runterfährt. Dann hätte ich mich nur aufgeschlachelt, wenn jemand anders gedacht hätte, dass das ist. Deswegen kam ich darüber, weil es vergleichbar mit dem Grimmonline war. Du bist eigentlich bei etwas sehr Schönem und bist halt trotzdem in ständiger Sorge, wie wird das jetzt hier vonstatten gehen.
Eigentlich war es ja keine Sorge, ich habe es dir ja gesagt.
Ja, aber du hast natürlich den Vorteil, dass du wahrscheinlich die Reaktion deiner Umwelt ganz anders wahrnimmst als dein Papa.
Nein, in dem Moment, wenn ich so ungerecht bei einem Preis verloren habe, ist es mir eigentlich egal, was nun die anderen sagen.
Du hast nicht verloren, das habe ich dir schon ein paar Mal versucht zu erklären.
Wie viele Fußballbücher wurden denn veröffentlicht in dem Jahr, in dem ihr nominiert wart? Als eines von wahrscheinlich acht Büchern maximal?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Aber dennoch, es ist ja dennoch eine Niederlage.
Okay, was hat denn das Buch jetzt im Nachhinein? Wir haben jetzt sehr viel über die Entstehung des Buchs gesprochen und auch warum das jetzt dann unter Klarnamen erschienen ist. 2017 ist das Hardcover erschienen, wir Wochenendrebellen, ein ganz besonderer Junge und sein Vater auf Stadion Tour durch Europa im Benevento-Verlag und jetzt später eben noch die Taschenbuchausgabe im Goldman-Verlag. Aber was hat denn das Buch, als dieses Ding, wie es jetzt hier auf diesem Tisch liegt, dann in der Retrospektive für euch bedeutet?
Also es war zunächst erstmal etwas, wo ich ähnlich wie in meinem Job erstmal so drangehe und sage, ok, du hast da jetzt was geschrieben, du musst jetzt wissen, was hast du jetzt im Anschluss gegebenenfalls noch zu tun. Das heißt, ich habe gefragt, hey, muss ich, wenn das Buch im Laden steht, gibt es da noch irgendwas, was mein Job ist oder ist das dann das Thema dann durch und das lügt dann im Laden und ist dann fertig? Und dann gab es den einzigen Termin, den wir dann vor Ort in Wals, glaube ich, war das, wenn ich mich recht erinnere. Nee, Salzburg, Salzburg war das direkt. In so einem kleinen Dachgeschossbüro saßen wir dann da oben, da war dann irgendwie Vertrieb und Marketing und da wurde dann halt mit Begrifflichkeiten um sich geschmissen, wo ich gesagt habe, ok, kenne ich mich alles nicht aus, weiß ich alles nicht. Und es gab dann die großen Listen, wer da jetzt alles kontaktet wird und hast du nicht gesehen und was sich dann daraus alles ergibt. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ok, das heißt ich muss mir dann irgendwie in der Veröffentlichungswoche Urlaub nehmen oder wie? Nein, nein, das kriegt man dann irgendwie alles auch so hin und so weiter. Und es passierte dann irgendwie tatsächlich auch durch diese Wechseleien eigentlich nicht viel, weil ich wurde dann übergeben an jemanden von Marketing quasi. Da wurde dann ein Termin vereinbart für das Veröffentlichungswochenende. Da sind wir dann in Wien gewiesen zusammen mit einem Redakteur vom Kurier. Und es gab eine Woche später nochmal einen Termin mit einem zweiten Medium hier in Deutschland. Und dann war das eigentlich so das Thema dann schon durch. Ich hatte aber parallel dazu halt dann, als ich gesehen habe, okay, da passiert so gar nichts. Und auch diese nicht Illusionen, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das sagen sollte, es spielte für mich nicht die entscheidende Rolle. Aber ich bin eigentlich schon davon ausgegangen, naja, das ist eine Tochter von Red Bull. Man kann denen ganz, ganz viele Dinge vorwerfen. Aber ein Produkt vermarkten, das sollten die eigentlich hinbekommen, bin ich jetzt zumindest von ausgegangen. Ich hatte dann eher Sorge, wie wird das gegebenenfalls sein?
Wäre ja auch cool gewesen, wenn unser Buch durch so einen Atmosphärensprung von Felix Baumgart.
Oh, da hätte ich jetzt nicht so Bock drauf.
Wieso?
Vor allem, wenn man jetzt weiß, wie der politisch tickt.
Ja, aber Hauptsache, ein Sprung erst mal aus 30 Kilometer Höhe.
Dann hätten wir selber springen müssen. Wieso? Ja, das wäre noch das Authentischste gewesen.
Ja, dann wäre das Buch so ein.
So war es dann halt parallel dazu etwas, dass ich gesagt habe, ich kümmere mich zum Teil auch ein bisschen selber drum und schreibe verschiedene Leute an. Und hatte zudem halt auch diese ganze Bloggerszene, die uns eigentlich über all die Jahre dann irgendwie auch immer so ein bisschen mit unterstützt und geholfen hat. Da hatte ich gesagt, Mensch, da will ich schon die Möglichkeit schaffen, dass dort ich nicht mich gegenüber einem Verlag rechtfertigen muss. Also du kriegst das Rezensionsexemplar für den Blog. Der hat ja nur eine Reichweite von X, Y oder Z. Das funktioniert nicht oder so. Sodass ich dort die Autorenexemplare plus noch mal ein kleines Paket obendrauf genutzt habe, um wirklich zu versuchen, alles, was uns in den acht Jahren so vor die Flinte kam und es in irgendeiner Art und Weise unterstützt begleitet hat, die Möglichkeit zu einem kostenlosen Rezensionsexemplar geben zu lassen. Und immer zusätzlich mit der Bedingung, dass ich sage, hey, es ist ein Rezensionsexemplar, wenn du es liest und in die Ecke schmeißt, ist es mir eigentlich auch egal, weil wir letztendlich einen recht guten Deal vereinbart haben, dass ich ein Honorar für dieses Buch bekommen habe, was wir in Auflage niemals erzielen. Doch, klar werden wir das schaffen. Gut, du siehst das wieder anders. Aber was wir in der Auflage nie schaffen. Das heißt, man konnte da relativ…
Werden wir auf jeden Fall.
Okay, du hast echt meinen Sohn. Das heißt, wir konnten da, was das angeht, relativ entspannt dran gehen. Und da kamen dann aber tatsächlich noch ganz, ganz viele Kontakte raus, wo wir noch… Das Thema Lesereise kam plötzlich erstmals auf, dass der Jochen Lohmann, Mitorganisator vom Elf-Millimeter-Fußball-Film-Festival und von Brot und Spiele, gesagt hat, Mensch, wie sieht es denn aus? Wollte nicht mal nach Berlin kommen für eine Lesung? Und das kam parallel in einer Zeit, wo Jason mich an ein anderes Versprechen erinnerte, wo es so um das Thema ging, dass wir eigentlich die Welt definitiv hier ein Stück besser machen müssen irgendwie. So dass ich gesagt habe, weißt du was Jason, wir machen jetzt so eine Lesereise, wir machen Berlin und wir kriegen auch in Hamburg, hatte ich mittlerweile schon Kontakt zum Mike vom FC St. Pauli, beziehungsweise vom Übersteiger oder vom Milan-Ton-Podcast und so dass klar war, wir haben zwei Lesungsorte und dann fahren wir dahin und das kostet die nichts und wir machen das umsonst und dann gibt es am Ende, sammeln wir ein paar Spenden ein und das überweisen wir an irgendeinen schönen Verein oder an irgendeine Stiftung, die was Gutes tun, dann ist auch dieses Versprechen abgehakt. Das war eigentlich so dann der Moment, wo es mal wieder eskaliert hat.
Das ist nicht eskaliert, das war logisch, ich habe es selber angekündigt.
Ja, aber du hast es nicht angekündigt, als ich dir in zwei Terminen zugestimmt habe. Auf der Lesung hast du es dann angekündigt.
Bei Anlesen der Presse, klar.
Ohne es mit dir zu besprechen.
Ja, dreimal.
Was hast du denn angekündigt? Du musst die Hörerinnen und Hörer, die das noch nicht wissen, ein bisschen ins Boot rühren.
Dass wir halt deine festen Spendenziele ausmachen, nicht nur zwei Lesungen, sondern erst habe ich gesagt, wir so lange lesen, bis wir 10.000 Euro vollmachen. Als wir 10.000 Euro voll hatten, habe ich gesagt, wir werden so lange lesen, bis wir 25.000 Euro vollmachen. Und als wir die 25.000 Euro hatten, habe ich gesagt, ich werde nochmal in separat Spendenziele von 10.000 Euro ausrufen.
Und die Spenden sammelt ihr eben im Rahmen eurer Lesereise, dass ihr einfach vorstellt, für wen ihr spendet. Das ist die Neven Subotage Stiftung, da können wir gleich auch noch kurz drüber reden, wie ihr da drauf gekommen seid. Und dann spenden eben die Anwesenen bei den Lesereisen vor Ort und aktuell steht ihr bei 32.500 Euro. Ich habe aufgerundet, bevor du mich korrigieren möchtest, die ihr allein durch das Lesen eures Buches gesammelt habt. Und warum die Neven Subotage Stiftung?
Also es war recht früh klar, dass wir das Thema Autismus, so wie es medial beleuchtet wird, sei es YouTube, sei es Google, wo auch immer man schaut. Selbst der Wikipedia-Eintrag wird von vielen, vielen Autisten sehr, sehr kritisch beäugt, weil er in der Formulierung teilweise recht unglücklich ist. Sodass wir eigentlich nie den Eindruck erwecken wollten, es hat auf dem Cover des Buchs – es steht nichts über Autismus – es gehört zum Rahmen der Geschichte dazu. Ja, aber wir wollten nichts in dem Kontext Autismus tun oder machen, weil auch nicht der Eindruck entstehen sollte, dass das Autismus etwas ist, wo man etwas gegen tun muss oder so in irgendeiner Art und Weise. Das heißt, das Thema war relativ schnell raus und wenn man dann so sagt, ok, was ist noch Thema des Buchs, das ist das Thema Fußball, was findet man so in dem Bereich, dann ist das etwas, wo man halt sehr, sehr schnell bei der Neven Subotage Stiftung landet. Arvaz selber ein unfassbar guter Typ ist und wo ich halt bei allen weiteren – es gibt ja mittlerweile wirklich, sei es die Robert Enke Stiftung, die einen sehr, sehr guten Job macht. Selbst die Philipp Lahm Stiftung macht einen fantastischen Job, halt medial nicht so präsent und es gibt da eine andere Herangehensweise. Aber ich hatte halt bei der Neven Subotage Stiftung am ehesten den Eindruck, von dem, was ich von außen gesehen habe, dass da wirklich persönlich jemand dahinter steht, weil er sagt, ihm ist der Inhalt oder das Ziel wichtig gegebenenfalls und ich bin beim ersten Mal bin ich dann alleine hingefahren nach Dortmund und hab mich dann dort mit jemandem getroffen und hab gesagt, okay, wir werden jetzt eine Lesereise machen, da wird jetzt nicht viel beisammenkommen, aber vielleicht gibt es auch noch zwei, drei andere Spinnereien, was uns nächstes Jahr einfällt und ich würde gern mehr über eure Arbeit erfahren, weil ich wollte halt nicht irgendwie, dass mir da ein weiterer Vorpaar unterläuft, dass ich irgendwas nicht berücksichtige in irgendeiner Art und Weise. Und als ich dann von der Arbeit gehört habe, was und wie und auch so zwei, drei Anekdotchen drumherum gehört habe, war ich dann schon extrem angetan, weil ich gesagt habe, wow, ich habe es mir effektiv und nachhaltig vorgestellt, aber es war also wirklich so komplett bis ins letzte Detail durchdacht und du hast halt auch in diesem Büro gespürt, wie da jeder wirklich mit Leidenschaft dabei ist und nicht einfach, dass das für die da irgendwie auch zum Teil einfach nur ein Job ist oder so. Und das war dann etwas, wo auf diesem Fuß hat Jason mich dann erwischt, dass wir aus den – wir machen mal zwei Lesungen. Ich glaube, auf beiden Lesungen kamen insgesamt dann irgendwie 200 Euro. Würde ich jetzt schätzen, ich sage genau, müsste man nochmal nachschauen, aber ich würde jetzt mal sagen, irgendwas um die 200 Euro kam zusammen. Wo er dann aber über die Neven Subbotage Stiftung erfahren hat, um einen ganzen Brunnen zu finanzieren, braucht es halt 10.000 Euro.
Also die Neven Subbotage Stiftung setzt sich eben dafür ein, dass in Afrika Leuten Zugang zu was?
Genau, die bauen nachhaltig Brunnen in der Tigray-Region in Nord-Ethiopien und ist eine Region, die, was dahingehend doppelt traurig ist, wo es sehr, sehr viele Brunnen gibt, von denen es auch tolle Fotos von der Einweihung gibt und die dann irgendwie vier Jahre später dann da wieder völlig brach vor sich hin liegen, weil sich halt niemand um die Wartung kümmert, um die Nachbereitung auch Menschen zu erklären, wie muss ich mit Wasser hygienisch umgehen, dass ich mein Vieh, was ich brauche, nicht aus demselben Trog trinken lassen kann, wie das, was ich nutze, gegebenenfalls um Essen zuzubreiten. Das sind alles Dinge, die man Menschen dann zum Teil beibringen muss. Als ich Jason damals, als ich von dem Termin zurückkam und so in der Zusammenfassung mir uns den Bericht angeschaut habe, er konnte das dann gar nicht fassen, er hat gesagt, ja wie, die haben keinen Zugang zu Wasser. Ja, die haben keinen Zugang zu Wasser, die haben keinen Wasserhahn, wo müssen die denn hin? So, ne, die haben nicht nur keinen Wasserhahn, sondern da müssen die Kinder, da gehört es so, wie hier Kinder in die Schule gehen, gehört es dazu, deren Job, dass die sich morgens auf den Weg machen mit Kanistern, die auf ihrer Rückkehr dann knappe 20 Kilo insgesamt wiegen. Und dann sind die halt mal sechs, sieben Kilometer durch die bei unglaublichen Temperaturen unterwegs, brauchen im Regelfall so vier bis sechs Stunden, um diese Arbeit zu verrichten, Wasser zu besorgen. Also das, was ich in der Selbstverständlichkeit morgens beim Duschen in zweieinhalb Minuten erledige oder so. Und das war etwas, was Jason so überhaupt nicht begreifen konnte am Anfang. Er hat gesagt, ja, das müssen wir halt ändern. Und so war halt auch er dann so ein bisschen gefangen und hat gesagt, also so einen Brunnen müssen wir auf jeden Fall schaffen. Und ich habe dann gesagt, wir können uns dann nochmal was überlegen, gegebenenfalls, dass wir einen Teil von dem Buch einnahmen. Ich hatte dann am Anfang noch so eine Affiliate-Seite angelegt, wo ich gesagt habe, naja, gut, dann kommt darüber noch was. Das hat so fantastisch geklappt. Da kam dann irgendwie 36, 50 zusammen oder so. War also ein völliger Reihenfall, sodass ich dann gesagt habe, okay, dann bleibt es halt bei dieser Lesereise. Und wir hängen dann gegebenenfalls dann noch einen Termin dran, weil es dann auch immer nach jeder Lesung kamen dann immer noch mal so ein, zwei Anfragen so aus dem Publikum. Könntet ihr euch auch vorstellen, dort zu lesen oder dort zu lesen? Und als Jason dann die Zehntausend ausgerufen hat, gab es da ja dann auch erstmal keine große Möglichkeit, dem zu entfliehen dann.
Und jetzt die 25.000 ausgerufen, aber auch echt.
Und es ist halt schon dann auch etwas, wo ich gesagt habe, wenn man – ich hatte es ja gerade angesprochen – so das Thema Autismus in den Medien oder die Klischees, die es darüber gibt, dieses extrem egoistische, nur-für-sicht-denkend etc. dass ich gesagt habe, Mensch, vielleicht ist Jason dann auch mit ein schöner Gegenbeweis, dass es definitiv nicht so ist. Er ist ein unglaublich sensibler, einfühlsamer Kerl, der dort dann sagt, ja, spielt sicherlich auch mit, dass man schön mit dem Zug dann zu so einer Lesereise, das spielt alles mit eine Rolle. Aber das ist schon durchaus auch oftmals harte Arbeit gewesen, als es eskaliert ist. Und so dass wir gesagt haben, okay, wir versuchen das mal.
Weil grimmig gegen den Begriff Eskalation, das war geplant.
Ja, für dich war es geplant. Für mich war es ähnlich wie grimme online Wort ist nicht möglich. Habe ich halt gerechnet, habe gedacht, nach zwei Lesungen hast du 200 Euro, du sollst jetzt auf Lesereise gehen, bis es 10.000 Euro sind. Da ist mir schon ein bisschen schwummerig geworden, wo ich gesagt habe, wie gehst du das an? Sodass wir dann angefangen haben, wir hatten vorher noch nicht mal eine Spendendose. Also bei der ersten Lesung habe ich dann auf dem Weg zur Lesung, habe ich gesagt, zum Jochen hast du irgendeine Vase da irgendwo, wo die dann mal ihren Euro reinschmeißen können. Sodass wir dann Flyer-Material von der Subotage Stiftung etc. also so zwei, drei Sachen optimiert haben. Jason dann seinen eigenen Text geschrieben hat für die Lesereise, wo er wirklich dieses Gesamtprojekt der Neven Subotage Stiftung einfach mal vorstellt, auch die Rahmenbedingungen, das Thema Wasser aus unterschiedlichsten Seiten beleuchtet. Und plötzlich bist du dann irgendwie bei den Offenbacher Kickers und du gehst mit 800 Euro Spende nach Hause oder so. Wo du dann merkst, okay, die Leute haben das Vertrauen zu dir. Wir machen das immer sehr transparent, dass wir mit dem Veranstalter zusammen an dem Abend noch das Geld zählen, dass die Leute wissen, die finanzieren nicht ihre Reisen dadurch und können es dann 24 Stunden später im Blog, in dem Konto, ganz transparent nachvollziehen, dass das Geld von uns zu 100 Prozent weitergeleitet worden ist. Und das Schöne ist halt bei der Neven Subotage Stiftung, dass auch alle Rahmenkosten, die sonst bei Stiftungen durchaus ja mal entstehen, Verwaltungskosten, Reisekosten etc. bei der Neven Subotage Stiftung zu 100 Prozent von Neven getragen werden. Das heißt, dieses 100 Prozent Wash-Projekt, so wie sie es nennen, bedeutet wirklich, dass jeder Euro, der bei der Subotage Stiftung landet, zu 100 Prozent direkt in ein Projekt einfließen kann, was sie vor Ort mit renommierten Firmen durchführen. Und wo Neven jetzt – sie sind jetzt gerade ja erst wieder zurückgekommen vor vier, fünf Wochen oder so – einmal im Jahr ist das eigentlich immer so die erste Phase der Fußballprofi-Erholung für ihn, dass er a. ins Büro nach Dortmund, wo er aber häufiger ist, dann aber auch nach Äthiopien fliegt und jetzt seit letztem Jahr immer dann auch mit Teilen der Unterstützer.
Und wie viele Stationen hat jetzt die Lesereise gemacht, wenn ihr jetzt eben bei diesen beeindruckenden 32.000 Euro angekommen seid inzwischen?
Ich denke, es sind jetzt irgendwas zwischen 35 und 40 Lesungen, wobei die Spendensumme zum Teil dann, zum Teil waren es diese Affiliate-Einnahmen vom Anfang. Wir haben dann einige Medientermine gehabt, wo uns eine Aufwandsentschädigung oder ein Honorar angeboten wurde, je nachdem, wo wir gesagt haben, nee, das soll entweder direkt oder es geht über uns dann dorthin. Und das ging so weit, dass es letztes Jahr, nee dieses Jahr war das sogar, wir dann sogar für Vorträge auf einer internationalen Autismuskonferenz gewucht worden, wo du dann so stehst und denkst, was läuft hier eigentlich? Ja, aber wo du dann erst mal so denkst, was läuft hier eigentlich für einen Film? Na ja, weil alle so einen mega professionellen Vortrag mit Präsentation und allem drum dran und so.
Ich hab mich so, eigentlich so gefühlt, als wäre ich immer da gewesen.
Weiß ich nicht. Also es war, ich fand's ein bisschen seltsam und du standest da, wir hatten halt nichts vorbereitet. Also es ging um das Thema Beziehung erleben und wir durften halt dementsprechend dann auch nicht irgendwie so unsere klassisches Lesereisen – Programm ist falsch gesagt, wir haben immer so einen groben Rahmen, wo wir wissen, dass es so ungefähr wie es läuft, aber so im Detail kann man das gar nicht planen, aber da hatten wir halt einfach eine Stunde, wo wir unsere Beziehung dann sprechen sollten oder eigentlich einen Vortrag halten sollten und dann haben wir dann einfach spontan eine Stunde über unsere Beziehung dort auf der Bühne gesprochen und haben dort dann auch einer internationalen Konferenz angemessen, dann halt auch ein hoheres Honorar bekommen, was wir dort spenden konnten. Und dass es halt immer wieder völlig Irre und Verrückte gibt, die im Rahmen ihrer Saisonspende liebe Grüße an den Gunnar nach Wehen in diesem Fall, der jetzt schon gesagt hat, ihr könnt gar nicht Ende August aufhören, ich möchte meine Saisonspende auch im nächsten Jahr gerne wieder eurem Projekt zugut kommen lassen. Ja, wir werden eine Lösung finden. Also das ist jetzt nicht das Thema. Und so auf unterschiedlichsten Wegen ganz, ganz viele Menschen so kleinere Ideen auch haben, wo sie sagen, Mensch, ich unterstütze euch auf diesen Weg oder ich mach das so und so. Und dann wirklich diese immense Summe zusammengekommen ist, die ich nicht für möglich gehalten hätte. Definitiv nicht. Ganz, ganz sicher nicht. Und die auch mich immer noch so ein bisschen aus den Socken haut. Das ist Geld in der Größenordnung, wo ich sonst nicht mit hantiere. Jason sieht das ein bisschen entspannter, aber es ist jetzt halt auch ein Cut erreicht. Die 10.000 Euro Ansage ohne Rücksprache, okay. Da habe ich mich im Nachgang auch ein bisschen gefreut über sein Engagement, über sein Handwerklichkeit.
Aber dann habe ich ja noch die 25.000 Euro Ansage gemacht. Und die Spendensammlung ist mit dem Ende der Leserei nicht vorbei. Ich habe ja in Mönchengladbach nochmal ein 10.000 Euro Ziel ausgerufen. Deswegen ist die Spendensammlung ja mit der Leserei nicht vorbei.
Wobei man da aber auch dann trennen muss. Bei den 25.000 Euro ist mir dann schon ein bisschen der Kragen geplatzt. Weil wir standen irgendwie bei 9, 5 oder irgendwie so was und du wusstest dann so, jetzt nähert sich einem Ende und es geht ja nicht darum, dass man sich nicht freut, was Gutes zu tun. Aber du bist halt wieder kontinuierlich unterwegs. Du hast wieder eine Frau und eine Tochter. Ja, trotzdem.
Nein, nicht trotzdem, das macht ja keinen Unterschied. Trotzdem ist immer so was… Was macht denn für einen Unterschied, ob wir nun auf Lesereise sind oder ob du halt arbeitest und ich mitkomme?
Du hast recht, mein Sohn. Zu Hause wartet trotzdem eine Frau und eine Tochter, die mich gerne mal zu Gesicht bekommen würden.
Aber die Verknüpfung ist doch Unsinn, weil sie hätte dich… Nach Ende der Lesereise werden sie dich ja nicht öfter sehen.
Du hast recht, mein Sohn. Was wir zwar so oft wie möglich miteinander verknüpft haben, also zur Lesung in Dortmund, sind die dann mitgekommen, wir sind dann das Wochenende da geblieben. Aber es bläht halt dann auch wieder die Kosten auf, die ja schon da sind. Also es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass wir dort, auch wenn wir komplett umsonst auftreten, in Anführungszeichen, dass da nicht dann doch im Hintergrund Kosten entstehen, die wir dank seines – er ist ja sehr genügsam im Regelfall, ich auch – also von daher ist es jetzt nicht so, dass wir dort irgendwie pauschal 500 Euro brauchen, um irgendwo ein Wochenende zu verbringen oder so. Aber du musst eine Übernachtung häufig mit einplanen und auch, wenn dort viele nette Angebote kommen, Mensch, ihr könnt hier bei uns oder so, das ist halt schon ein bisschen schwierig. Müssen wir machen?
Wir können ja sogar aktiv nachfragen.
Ja, das können wir gerne beim nächsten Mal machen. So ist das dann etwas, das bei den 25.000 Euro für mich, als er das angekündigt hat, ist ja jetzt Schluss. Also jetzt kümmern wir uns noch um die Städte, die jetzt noch so in der Pipeline sind. Es gab also ganz, ganz viele Städte, die Rostock oder so zum Beispiel mit denen diskutieren wir jetzt seit anderthalb Jahren, wo wir immer gucken, wann kommen die nächsten Spieltagsansetzungen? Wann spielt Hansa? Wie ist es möglich, mit dem Zug an einem Wochenende, wo keine Ferien sind, hinzukommen, eine Lesung zu haben und wieder zurück und im Idealfall vielleicht auch noch ein Hansa spielen, wenn du schon mal da bist oder so. Deswegen schieben wir dort immer so ein bisschen. Und da hab ich halt gesagt, jetzt ist Schluss.
Und ich hab trotzdem noch mal…
Jetzt machen wir nur noch die Lesungen in den Städten, die noch offen sind und für die Restsumme musst du dir selber was einfallen lassen. Das war da bei mir beim Stand von 10.000.
Ich hab so gelegt, dass ich noch nicht mal so gemacht hab, dass ich für die Restsumme bis 25.000 Euro mich selber kümmern, sondern ich hab dann noch mal, über die 25.000 hinaus, noch mal 10.000 aufgerufen.
Weil wir die 25.000 dann schon voll hatten, was wir zu dem Zeitpunkt ja noch nicht ahnen konnten. Und dann waren die 25.000 voll und dann hat er halt nochmal auf einer Lesung am Bökelberg gesagt, so und jetzt 10.000 und dann hab ich gesagt, jetzt machen wir mal hier mal schon einen Cut. Das ist jetzt so sein eigenständiges Projekt, da will er mit einem eigenen Buch, ein komplett eigenes Projekt, da unterstütze ich ihn, da kommt er auf mich zu und er sagt, da brauche ich jetzt Hilfe, aber ansonsten hab ich damit gar nichts zu tun.
Aber wir packen denn das Projekt von der Spendensumme auf das jetzt drauf, damit ich nicht bei null anfange.
Wir können das damit draufpacken, aber es ist trotzdem was anderes.
Das ist wie mit den Twitter-Followern, wie mit den Twitter-Followern.
Also das ist so die Situation.
Jetzt haben wir viel über das Buch gesprochen, viel über die Lesereise gesprochen und ein Thema, was auch immer wieder so mit dabei war, Mirko, war eben das Bewusstsein und der Willen, über Autismus aufzuklären am Beispiel, so wie ihr ihn erlebt, ohne einen Anspruch zu haben, jetzt für alle zu sprechen, weil das eben auch gar nicht möglich ist. Kannst du uns da noch mal ein bisschen ins Thema reinholen? Vielleicht angefangen bei der Diagnose des Autismus. Wie hast du das erlebt und welche Konsequenzen hatte das dann aktiv für euer Leben?
Also die Diagnose selbst habe ich, ich hätte jetzt fast gesagt als Außenstehender erlebt, weil es irgendwie so lief, wie es in der Zeit sehr, sehr häufig lief, dass meine Frau sich um ganz, ganz viele Dinge zu Hause gekümmert hat und ich eigentlich dann beruflich so viel unterwegs war und wir uns dann irgendwie immer mal so kurzfristig abgestimmt haben, was liegt denn da jetzt eigentlich so an. Und wir haben damals hier in der Nähe von München gelebt, als der vom Kindergarten Erzieherin auf uns zugekommen ist und gesagt hat, also es wäre nicht schlecht, wenn Sie Ihren Sohn mal begutachten lassen. Und zu meiner Frau gesagt haben, naja, er spielt halt immer alleine und eigentlich spielt er gar nicht, sondern in der Lego-Ecke oder in der Bauklotz-Ecke wird so alles nach Formen und Farben sortiert. Am liebsten steht er eigentlich am Fenster und liest die Kennzeichen von den Autos auf dem Parkplatz vor oder er sortiert halt die Verkehrsschilder. Es gab so kleine Plastikverkehrsschilder, die da irgendwie so aufgestellt wurden und hat sich dann immer mehrfach erklären lassen, was welches Schild bedeutet und hat dann im Anschluss erzählt, das ist das Stoppschild, das ist dafür, das ist dafür und hat dann auch die Kinder gemassregelt, wenn die da mit ihrem Auto auf den Straßen lang gefahren sind oder es irgendwie einer am Stopf ist, dann war die Hölle los und das war alles ein Feedback, wo ich erst mal gesagt habe, okay, kann ich nachvollziehen, dass das ungewöhnlich ist.
Vor allem, er war dann noch sehr jung.
Ja, ja, da war er vier, würde ich jetzt sagen, drei, dreieinhalb, vier oder so. Also so dreieinhalb war er, als er diagnostiziert worden ist, würde ich sagen. Und dann hatten wir einen Termin bei der Caritas. Ich glaube, zum ersten Termin ist meine Frau dann sogar alleine hingegangen und dann beim zweiten Termin sagte sie, jetzt komm da doch mal mit. Und ich hatte eigentlich eher das Gefühl, wir lebten, wie gesagt, hier eigentlich eher in der dörflichen Region, hier in der Ecke, in der Nähe von München. Und ähm, ausländisch klingen dann Nachname, die Frau ist nicht mal in Deutschland geboren, ähm, bei der Maibaum-Aufstellung waren wir nicht dabei, sowieso nicht bei allen Festen, etc. Also es war jetzt nicht so…
Halten nicht von Dorfgemeinschaften.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt hast du aber da noch weniger von gehalten, bzw. das hat dich gar nicht interessiert, weil du es nicht mitbekommen hast. Aber es war halt jetzt auch nicht so, dass wir jetzt irgendwie nicht wollten, sondern es hat sich einfach zeitlich gar nicht so ergeben, dass wir dort irgendwo Anschluss gefunden haben oder dort irgendwie eine Dorfgemeinschaft integriert haben. Deswegen war ich auch sehr skeptisch, als diese Erzieherin kam und ich dachte, naja, gut, okay, dann ist es halt so, unser Sohn soll halt der Außenseiter sein und wir schlechte Eltern.
Ich find's gut. Außenseiter.
Und dann kamen die ersten Termine und es zeichnete sich dann nach und nach ein Bild, dass es dann irgendwann einen Abschlusstermin geben sollte, nachdem sie Jason dann auch im Kindergarten beobachtet hatten, bei uns zu Hause noch mal waren, etc. Und dann sagte die Dame halt, naja, sie darf halt keine Diagnose stellen, aber sie geht davon aus, dass Jason Asperger-Autist ist. Und das war dann erstmal etwas in der Kurzvariante, wo du bei Autismus natürlich schon dann erstmal so ein klassisches Bild vor Kopf hast von irgendwelchen Menschen, die monoton vor sich hin und her wippen oder Rain Man ist dann wieder so der Klassiker, den eigentlich, wo jeder so das immer direkt mit diesem Film in Verbindung bringt. Und haben dann die Empfehlung bekommen, uns einen Termin zu geben zu lassen hier im Hexer-Klinikum in München, die die Diagnostik machen können. Haben dann da am selben Nachmittag angerufen, die haben gesagt, ja, ist kein Problem, sie kriegen einen Termin, der ist dann und dann. Und das war dann irgendwie so sechs Monate später, also du bist dann erst mal da so sechs Monate komplett allein gelassen mit einer Info, die dich sowieso schon überfordert hat. Wir haben dann den Fehler gemacht, dass wir sehr viel gelesen haben, aber alles, was man so dann so googelt, die ersten Treffer, was kommt da so, YouTube, die ersten Videos, wie heilt man Autismus und was weiß ich nicht, alles, was man da findet und war uns dann aber zum Glück relativ schnell klar, dass das wirklich ein Bereich ist, wo es auch ums Geldverdienen geht. Also wo wirklich mit martialischsten Methoden, wirklich Behandlungsmethoden versucht wird, Geld zu verdienen mit Autismusheilung oder sonst irgendwas für so einen Blödsinn. Und für uns war es zu dem Zeitpunkt etwas, dass wir wussten, okay, unser Sohn hat eine Behinderung und als wir bei der Diagnostik dann ein halbes Jahr später, beim Abschlussgespräch, dann immer wieder gefragt haben, okay, jetzt erklären Sie uns noch mal, was bedeutet das konkret? Ich habe jetzt verstanden, er ist Aspergerautist. Ich habe verstanden, es gibt eine gewisse Bandbreite an Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten, aber Sie müssen uns noch mehr sagen können als das, das kann ja nicht alles sein. Und es ist dann die sehr drastische Formulierung getroffen worden, Sie werden sehr schnell lernen müssen, dass Ihr Kind behindert ist und dass es sehr viele Dinge gibt, die er nicht schaffen kann und die er niemals erreichen wird, die für andere Kinder selbstverständlich sind. Andere Kinder? Ja, so hat er es gesagt. War ja nicht meine Aussage. Und mit der Info sind wir dann dort so entlassen worden. Die ersten Reaktionen waren dann, dass wir gesagt haben, wir werden mehr Unterstützung brauchen, weil halt auch schon spürbar war, dieses, was wir vorhin gesagt haben, dieses, wenn man DVD schaut, drei, vier, fünf, sechsmal hintereinander dieselbe. Meine Frau war abends, wenn ich von zwölf Stunden Arbeit nach Hause kam, war sie völlig fertig mit der Welt und hat gesagt, Schatz, ich hab heute nichts geschafft, weil ich den ganzen Tag versucht hab, mit ihm mitzuhalten und versucht habe, bei ihm zu sein und ihn zu unterstützen und wenn ich dann irgendwie kurz weg war, war sofort Alarm. Die war also da auch sehr schnell mit den Nerven runter, sodass wir dann entschieden haben, wieder nach Nordhessen zu ziehen, weil dort meine Eltern leben, wir uns dort mehr Unterstützung versprachen und weil wir auch wussten, aus Kontakt mit dem Autismus-Therapie-Institut, dass dort hinsichtlich Fördermöglichkeiten ein besserer Rahmen besteht insgesamt. Und das war eigentlich so der Beginn des Ganzen und dann war es meiner Frau zu verdanken, die sich dort sehr, sehr tief ins Thema rein gefuchst hat, die alles Mögliche an Fördermöglichkeiten, an Therapiemöglichkeiten sich angehört hat und wir haben dann sehr, sehr früh Jason mit eingebunden und haben gesagt, okay, willst du das mal versuchen, da wird das gemacht oder da wird dies gemacht. Sodass dann von Ergotherapie, Logopädie, gemeinsame Gruppenbewegungstherapie, Autismus-Therapiezentrum in Gruppe, Autismus-Therapie-Institut in Einzelgesprächen, also so ganz, ganz viel. Die Woche war halt gut gefüllt. Und immer so in gewissen Abständen hat meine Frau dann so Interdisziplinärtreffen organisiert, wo dann Kindergärtnerin, Erzieherin bzw. später dann auch die Lehrerin, Autismus-Therapie-Institut, wo alle zusammenkamen, inklusive Jason, und dann besprochen wurde, Mensch, was sind denn die Baustellen, wo wir gegebenenfalls drangehen müssten? Und es war aber immer so mit einem sehr defizitären Blickwinkel. Und das war etwas, was meiner Frau und mir dann irgendwann aufgefallen ist. Sodass sie dann gesagt hat, naja, es kann ja nicht sein, dass wir uns nur um die Vermeidung von Schwächen oder die Bearbeitung von Schwächen unseres Kindes kümmern müssen. Oder kümmern dürfen.
Kein Kind.
Ja, unseres Sohnes. Sodass sie dann angefangen hat wirklich auch zu gucken, ne, wenn er der Meinung ist, die Ergotherapie oder die Logopädie ist etwas, was auch nichts bringt und auch nichts zu erkennen ist, dann lässt man das gegebenenfalls halt mal weg. Dann werden halt nicht fünf Nachmittage die Woche Schwächen bekämpft, sondern man kümmert sich vielleicht ein oder zwei Nachmittage darum, auch irgendwelche Stärken zu stärken. Und hat ihn dann irgendwann für den Physik-Kitz-Club angemeldet. Wollte. Oder wollte für den Physik-Kitz-Club ihn anmelden. Was dann auch mit so ein Knackpunkt war, zu merken, Mensch, welche Dimensionen da erreicht werden, wenn man nicht wirklich auf Biegen und Brechen versucht, irgendjemanden für die Gesellschaft in einem gewissen Maß zu normieren, sondern vielleicht sagt, ja, da ist ein kleiner Lispelfehler, der stört ihn nicht, der stört uns nicht, dann ist es erst mal so, gegebenenfalls. Und auch in den Bewegungsabläufen, was Ergotherapie, was die ganze Motorik angeht, dann zu sagen, nee, jetzt geht er halt in den Physik-Club und kümmert sich da drum. Und hat da dann spannenderweise sowas wie Selbstständigkeit, er muss dort Kontakt zu anderen Leuten aufnehmen, die ihm bei gewissen Sachen helfen, dann ja auch selber auf eine ganz, ganz andere Art und Weise gelernt insgesamt. Das war, glaube ich, so der entscheidende Schlüssel für eine Entwicklung, wo wir heute im Rückblick sagen, ja, wir haben noch eine Menge Schwierigkeiten, die wir so gemeinsam haben. Ich finde schon, dass wir weiterhin in einer Situation sind, dass wir nicht als Familie agieren zum Beispiel.
Wir haben ja schon mehrmals darüber gesprochen, eigentlich zu dem Schluss gekommen, dass es dafür keine Lösung gibt.
Ja, und da habe ich ja gesagt, das sehe ich halt anders.
Da hast du aber noch keine Lösung präsentiert.
Richtig, ja. Aber das muss ja weiterhin Ziel bleiben.
Aber lass uns nochmal kurz darüber sprechen, was Autismus ist. Also vielleicht kannst einmal du, Mirko, aus deiner Sicht sagen, worum es sich dabei handelt. Und dann würde mich Jason, wenn du magst, aus sehr deiner Sicht darauf interessieren.
Wenn ich mich grob an dem Wikipedia-Beitrag danach so ein bisschen orientiere, dann ist es vielleicht am einfachsten, weil es immer ein bisschen schwierig ist. Ich habe eigentlich relativ wenig Ahnung von Autismus. Ich habe sehr, sehr viel Ahnung von meinem Sohn, der Autist ist. Und mein Sohn ist halt innerhalb eines sehr, sehr breiten Spektrums diagnostiziert. Und in diesem Spektrum gibt es halt auch noch nicht mal mehr. Damals ist er ja noch als Asperger-Autist diagnostiziert worden. Diese Trennung vermeidet man heute mittlerweile sogar, sondern man spricht eigentlich nur noch von einer Autismus-Spektrumsstörung. Und in diesem Spektrum bewegen sich halt sowohl der Asperger-Autismus, aber halt auch zum Beispiel der frühkindliche Autismus. Weil es halt eigentlich nicht mehr so dieses ganz klare Bild gibt, wo man sagt, ah ja, okay, wenn er dort in dem Bereich Motorik oder in dem Bereich dort und dort so abschneidet, dann ist es Asperger-Autismus und da ist das. Sondern es sind wirklich sehr, sehr fließende Übergänge insgesamt. Wenn ich es von der Beschreibung her sehe, es gibt dann immer so sehr, sehr viel pseudoromantische Beschreibungen, es ist eine Gabe und was weiß ich nicht alles. Das halte ich für sehr, sehr, sehr gefährlich und sehr, sehr, sehr problematisch und schwierig. Es ist eine Behinderung und es ist auch sehr, sehr wichtig, dass uns allen bewusst ist, dass es eine Behinderung ist. Und es ist gleichzeitig aber – und das ist das Entscheidende, was meine Frau und ich auch lernen mussten – es ist ein entscheidender Bestandteil von Jason's Persönlichkeit. Es ist etwas, was ihn 24 Stunden am Tag, sieben Tage die Woche rund um die Uhr prägt, in all seinem Tun, all seinem Handeln, in allem, wie er sich gibt und wie er sich äußert. Und dass es dort auch etwas ist, wo es uns nicht zusteht, zu versuchen, ihn durch Therapien oder Ähnliches für die Gesellschaft in irgendeiner Form zu konditionieren. Konkret runtergebrochen bei ihm bedeutet das, dass Jason mit der Motorik gewisse Schwierigkeiten hat. Also wenn er die 400 Meter läuft, dann sollte man einen kleinen Bogen um ihn herum Platz lassen, weil man dann schon gegebenenfalls die ein oder andere Hacke abbekommen kann.
Naja, vor allem wenn man sich irgendwie oder wenn man sich bedrängt oder wenn angenommen, jemand kommt mit so nah und es ist eine Menschenmenge, dann trägt sich einfach bewusst jemand entschieden bei einem, um Platz zu verschaffen.
Genau. Berührungen werden halt sehr sehr schnell als Angriff wahrgenommen, was dann dementsprechend dann auch wieder seine Reaktion darauf zeigt. Es gibt ganz ganz viele Schwierigkeiten im Bereich so sozialer Umgang, wobei auch dort ich mit dem Begriff, es ist eine Entwicklungsstörung oder da gibt es die und die Schwierigkeiten, gibt es halt auch mittlerweile so diesen Blickwinkel, den ich darauf habe, du brauchst bei Jason halt nicht zwischen den Zeilen lesen, sondern du kriegst es sehr klar und deutlich mitgeteilt, und kannst dir jegliche Interpretationsmöglichkeiten, die kannst du dir komplett ersparen. Die brauchst du definitiv nicht. Das kann sehr hart sein, insbesondere als Vater oder als Mutter. Ich erinnere mich noch dran, wie er abends mal so neben seiner Mutter im Bett lag und sie ihn so anhimmelte und er dann nur so so sagt, was guckst du mich eigentlich so blöde an? Das ist dann halt jetzt nicht so das, was die Mami dann an dem Abend hören will, gegebenenfalls. Aber so hat er es halt in dem Moment wahrgenommen und haut es dann halt auch raus. Ich empfinde es in ganz ganz vielen Bereichen mittlerweile als sehr sehr angenehm, weil ich, während ich damals auf Schalke noch verunsichert war, ist bei dir alles in Ordnung, geht es dir gut und er sagt dann ja. Und ich weiß, naja meint er wirklich ja oder wie muss ich das jetzt verstehen, kann ich ihn heute was fragen, wenn ich eine Antwort bekomme und er sagt mir, das ist kein Problem, dann weiß ich, das ist kein Problem. Im Umkehrschluss weiß ich aber auch, wenn er mir sagt, das ist ein Problem, dann weiß ich, okay, das ist jetzt ein Problem. Und so gibt es ganz viele Blickwinkel auf die Behinderungen, wo ich sage, man muss lernen, damit umzugehen, auch aus Elternsicht heraus. Man darf es nicht beschönigen, man darf es nicht zu dieser Gabe hochstilisieren oder zu irgendwelchen Sachen. Und man muss sich jederzeit bewusst sein, ja, es ist eine Behinderung und ja, sie ist nicht heilbar.
Na, ich sehe es halt grundsätzlich so, es sind, oder der Mensch hat ja quasi zwei Gehirnhälften, ob man das tatsächlich auf diese Funktionen einteilen kann, das ist mittlerweile dann doch sehr umstritten, aber der Mensch hat zwei Gehirnhälften, das ist ja sicher. Und sicher ist auch, dass gewisse Gehirnhälften doch gewisse Funktionen zumindest stärker übernehmen als die andere. Also, dass zumindest so grob aufgeteilt ist. Und auch, dass für manche Fähigkeiten wiederum, oder manche Dinge, einfach eine Verkopplung von zwei oder drei Fähigkeiten sind, die man kombinieren muss, um ein konkretes Problem zu lösen. Und manchmal sind dann diese Fähigkeiten, die man anwenden muss, auch in verschiedenen Gehirnhälften quasi lokalisiert. Die Theorie ist quasi, dass bei Auslismus die Verbindungen zwischen den beiden Gehirnhälften weniger stark ausgeprägt sind, während was dazu führt, dass Aufgaben die eine Gehirnhälfte alleine erledigen kann, noch hoch funktionaler gelöst werden können, aber dass zum Beispiel Dinge, die eigentlich eine Kombination verschiedener Fähigkeiten voraussetzen, dass es da eben Schwierigkeiten gibt.
Kannst du da ein Beispiel nennen?
Ich weiß nicht genau, welche Fähigkeiten wo lokalisiert sind, aber wenn es einfach nur sich um Dinge um Dinge merken geht, um Verknüpfungen herstellen, um das Präsentieren von Dingen oder einfach so was, da bin ich zum Beispiel sehr gut drin, während Dinge, wo man irgendwie kombinieren muss, das Gehörte zusätzlich zu irgendeinem Kontext oder so. Erstens kann ich diesen Kontext irgendwie nicht so gut aufnehmen, aber zweitens sehe ich es auch gar nicht als meine Verantwortung oder meine Pflicht, zu gucken, was der andere nun meint oder denkt, sondern ich sehe es als meine Pflicht, zu gucken, was der andere sagt und darauf zu reagieren. Aber nicht als meine Verantwortung, dort zwischen den Zeilen zu lesen und zu gucken, was er meint.
Also dann so Dinge wie Ironie sind wahrscheinlich dann manchmal schwierig und das sich in jemand anderen hinein zu versetzen. Kannst du das sich in andere Leute rein zu versetzen? Das ist eine doofe Floske, aber zumindest so ein bisschen nachzuvollziehen, wie die Außenperspektive jetzt vielleicht auch etwas sein könnte, was du gerade ja aus deiner Innenperspektive erlebst?
Das geht aber auch genau in jemanden hinein zu versetzen. Oder ein Perspektivwechsel ist allgemein auch philosophisch ausgeschlossen.
Bei jedem Menschen.
Emotional nicht.
Wenn wir mal das Beispiel nehmen, das wir vorhin hatten von der Preisverleihung in Nürnberg. Als du aufgestanden bist und zu Berufen angesetzt hast, erschließt sich das für dich, dass das für deinen Paps ein schlechtes Gefühl ist?
Ein schlechtes, vielleicht, aber es ist philosophisch nicht möglich, in der Hinsicht in jemanden hinein zu versetzen, dass man weiß, wie nun diese äußeren Reize, die sich klar beschreiben lassen, und was die nun tatsächlich auslögen oder was sie wirken. Man kann sich ja immer nur auf Aussagen verlassen. Aussagen sind immer fehlbar.
Aber man kann ja eine Tendenz haben. Man kann ja eine Tendenz haben, ob man sagt, wenn ich jetzt dies und dies tue, dann wird man gegenüber das tendenziell eher positiv.
Das war mir in jedem Fall sehr durchbewusst. Und ich habe es bewusst erklärt.
Genau, aber darauf zieh ich ab. Also, dir ist dann das durchaus bewusst, dass du sagst, ich mach das jetzt, bei mir ist das wichtig. Das finde ich ja auch akzeptabel, weil das geht. Aber dir ist dann durchaus auch bewusst, dass andere das dann vielleicht anders wahrnehmen oder schlecht wahrnehmen oder vielleicht auch eine schlechte Meinung von dir haben. Aber das ist dir dann egal.
Also ein schönes Beispiel, wo er es mir mal erklärt hat, ist, dass er kann euch jetzt draußen erklären, mit der Wetterkonstellation von heute oder Wetterphänomenen insgesamt klimatische Bedingungen, da könnte er aus dem Stehgreif wahrscheinlich jetzt einen 45-minütigen Monolog mit allen Details halten. Gleichzeitig wäre er aber nicht in der Lage, dieses Wissen so umzusetzen, dass wenn er vor dem Kleiderschrank steht, zu entscheiden, ziehe ich eine kurze oder eine lange Hose an, ziehe ich ein T-Shirt oder ein Polo an, brauche ich heute eine Übergangsjacke, ja oder nein, um welche Schuhe ziehe ich an. Und gibt es da auch so allgemeingültige Regeln, was passt gegebenenfalls farblich, kommt noch dazu, die dann ihm auch gänzlich einfach komplett Schnuppe sind insgesamt. Das kommt noch dazu. Und diese Diskrepanz, die gibt es in ganz, ganz, ganz vielen Bereichen, dass du etwas im Theoretischen, wo du sagst, wow, was ist hier, und im nächsten Moment hast du etwas, was in diesem Kontext steht, wo du sagst, ja, das kann ja jetzt nicht sein, dass das jetzt nicht umgesetzt wird oder so. Und das hat aber jetzt bei seinem Forschungsprojekt ganz gut geklappt, wo er dann gemerkt hat, ich komme jetzt dort an gewisse Grenzen, jetzt brauche ich dort praktisch aber das und das, wo er dann immer wieder abwägen musste, hole ich mir jetzt Unterstützung, was ich eigentlich nicht will. Ich will ja mein Projekt alleine machen, ich will keinen Kontakt zu anderen haben. Gleichzeitig will ich aber weiterkommen, wo er wirklich lernen musste, für sich so abzuwägen und dort immer dann noch ein gutes Stückchen weitergekommen ist.
Ja, vielleicht sollten wir dazu noch ein bisschen was erklären. Also wir haben vorhin schon besprochen, das erste Spiel damals in Leverkusen war im Alter von sechs Jahren. Jetzt bist du schon 14, jetzt bist du 14 Jahre. Magst du uns kurz erklären, was machst du denn für ein Forschungsprojekt? Wie ist es im Physik-Kids-Club?
Da bin ich ja nicht drin.
Genau, ich habe diese Tür gerade geöffnet.
Dann müssten wir eigentlich erst den Tag erklären, wo Mami dort hingekommen ist.
Ja, dann mach das doch.
Also wir sind dann dort hingegangen, mit Mami's Ziel mich dort anzumelden. Und mir war grundsätzlich auch hartig nichts dagegen, es hieß ja nicht Kinder, sondern Kids. Gegen den Begriff habe ich erstmal nichts. Und deswegen haben wir das dann auch so gemacht, sind dahingegangen und sind dort ins Büro gegangen. Und dann hat Mami gefragt, ja wir möchten mich da dafür anmelden und dann war dort direkt der Leiter des Forschungszentrums – oder nee, das war nicht der Leiter des Forschungszentrums, das war derjenige, der drunter im Büro saß. Und die hat die Anmeldung dafür am Dienstag oder am Donnerstag oder irgendwie so, also kommen sie dann und dann wieder. Und dann habe ich mich eingemischt und habe gefragt, was macht man denn eigentlich im Kids Club? Dann hat er gefragt, ja was interessiert sich denn so? Dann habe ich gesagt, ich nenne ein paar Beispiele, dann habe ich angefangen, Quantenmechanik, Chaos-Theorie, Kosmologie, Schwarze Löcher und habe halt ein bisschen…
Wie alt warst du da, Entschuldigung?
Ich glaube, es war vierte Klasse, also zehn. Ja, zehn.
So ganz normale Themen.
Und wie gesagt, habe ich dann davon halt erzählt. Und er hat dann auch gar nicht weitergeholt, sondern hat gleich per Durchsage den Leiter des Forschungszentrums ins Büro geholt, weil er sich, glaube ich, mit der Unterhaltung ein bisschen überfordert. Und dann kam halt der Leiter des Forschungszentrums selbst und ich habe dem dann halt alles nochmal erklärt, was mich interessiert und so. Und dann haben wir uns halt einfach ein bisschen unterhalten. Er hat halt ein paar Fragen gestellt und am Ende der Unterhaltung kam dann halt heraus, dass ich mein eigenes Forschungsprojekt bekomme, auch mit Finanzmitteln vom Forschungszentrum finanziert, zum Thema Chaos-Theorie. Und ja, das Projekt höre ich jetzt seit vier Jahren.
Und kannst du uns noch mehr erklären, was du im Bereich der Chaos-Theorie machst? Und vor allem, das hat sich jetzt gerade so angehört, du hast es jetzt auch, glaube ich, eingereicht für einen Preis. Du bist da jetzt zu einem Abschluss gekommen jetzt nach vier Jahren, oder?
Nein, ein Abschluss ist noch in weiter Ferne.
Okay, gut, das scheint dir aber mit vielen Dingen sozusagen, die du angehst, fällt mir gerade so auf. Ich erkenne einen roten Faden.
Ich habe jetzt so drei oder vier Zwischenziele auf dem Weg erreicht, die schon wichtige Erkenntnisse waren. Aber ich bin also fertig, bin ich noch lange nicht. Ich sehe das Projekt noch mindestens drei Jahre in die Zukunft reichen. Mindestens.
Aber du müsstest vielleicht das Projekt nochmal genauer definieren.
Das ist aber schwierig zu erklären. Also wie gesagt, das grundlegende Thema ist Chaos-Theorie. Chaos bedeutet, dass eigentlich – das sind sogenannte nicht-linear Systeme, die Chaos erzeugen können. Chaos bedeutet, dass eine kleine Störung, also wirklich eine sehr, sehr kleine Störung, eine infinitesimale Störung sogar, eine so große Wirkung haben kann, dass quasi dieses System komplett aus seinem Zustand gebracht wird. Und dieser Endzustand dann so anders ist, dass man ja gar nicht mehr sagen kann, okay, wie war das denn das System denn vor der Störung? Was für eine Störung war das? Weil es einfach so einen großen Einfluss hat. Unser Sonnensystem ist ein chaotisches System, das Klima ist ein chaotisches System, also es gibt ganz viele große, wichtige chaotische Systeme für uns. Und als chaotisches System habe ich mich für das Chaos-Pendel entschieden. Das ist quasi, man hängt an einem Pendel, ein zweites Pendel dran. Und wenn man das dann quasi schwingt, dann wirkt quasi das erste Pendel pendelt. Und mit dieser Bewegung beeinflusst es, wie das zweite pendelt. Und die Bewegung des zweiten Pendels beeinflusst wieder das erste. Und so ist es so eine Art Rückkopplung.
Und dann kann man es quasi nicht mehr im Nachhinein kalkulieren, warum jetzt…
Genau, weil es sich halt irgendwie überlagert, diese beiden Drehpendel. Periodenverdopplung nennt man das. Und ich habe mich dort halt konzentriert auf eine Theorie namens Ergodentheorien. Und ja, versuche sie halt, das ist ein mathematisches Modell. Und ich versuche halt herauszufinden, unter welchen Begebenheiten dieses Theorien in der Realität gilt. Und in welchem Umfang es gilt. Und ich habe jetzt auch quasi eine Ergänzung, eine eigene Theorie entwickelt, die ich jetzt durch Simulation überprüfen werde. Ich mache gerade eine Einführung in Python programmieren und in Analysis.
Das erklärt ja vielleicht auch ganz gut, warum man manchmal auch von Inselbegabungen oder eben dieses Wort Gabe in den Mund nimmt, wenn man über Autismus spricht. Weil das ist ja nichts Normales, dass man im Alter von 14 Jahren über Dinge spricht. Selbst wenn ich das jetzt nachgegoogelt hätte nebenher, ich werde das nie so durchdrungen haben wie Jason. Kann man denn dann erklären, woher das kommt, ohne dass wir jetzt eben so tun wollen, als wäre das eine Gabe?
Ja, also bei dem Thema Inselbegabung ist es ja sogar mittlerweile definiert. Also es gibt innerhalb des Spektrums der Autisten gibt es noch die sogenannten Savants. Das ist auch quasi das, was man im Film Rain Man gegebenenfalls sieht. Und das sind auch die Autisten, die immer wieder medial extrem durchstechen. Also das berühmteste Beispiel – ich komme jetzt nicht auf seinen Namen – ist der gute Mann, der mit dem Hubschrauber über Städte fliegt und die dann eins zu eins abzeichnet. Also er fliegt einmal drüber und zeichnet die dann komplett auf sechs Meter große Leinwände. Und das stimmt jedes Detail. Also das ist völlig, völlig, völlig irrsinnig. Und da spricht man dann wirklich von einer Inselbegabung, bei diesen Savants. Die Savants wiederum sind aber, glaube ich, ich hoffe, ich sage jetzt keine falsche Zahl, es sind, glaube ich, 0, 01% aller Autisten sind Savants nochmal. Bei Jason ist es eigentlich so, dass es keine klassische Inselbegabung ist, sondern das ist wirklich eine sehr, sehr hohe Auffassungsgabe. Das, was er eben ansprach mit den beiden Gehirnhälften, die dann wirklich separat für sich vielleicht dann doch etwas besser funktionieren als bei seinem Papa, der vielleicht dann in der Kombi dann wieder etwas stärker ist, gepaart mit einem sehr, sehr hohen Interesse und dann halt auch mit einem unglaublichen, ausgeprägten Ehrgeiz. Ich meine, er macht das seit vier Jahren. Ich hatte gestern einen beruflichen Termin. Wir sind gestern Mittag losgefahren. Also er war gestern mal so eben noch mal sechs Stunden im Forschungszentrum, bevor wir losgefahren sind.
Sechs Stunden haben wir aber nicht gereicht. In sechs Stunden habe ich nur eine Einführung in Differentialgleichungen geschafft, die ich brauche.
Das weiß ich, aber ich bin ja die...
Es ist nicht das Typischste für jemanden im Alter von 14 Jahren, sich einem Thema so sehr hinzugeben.
Naja, ich glaube, dass die Intensität, sich einem Thema hinzugeben, auch bei anderen ergeben ist.
Ja, das mag vielleicht sein, aber speziell bei solchen Themen und dann so in die Tiefe zu dringen, das ist halt schon sehr, sehr speziell. Ihm fallen dort halt Dinge leichter, die uns sehr, sehr schwer fallen. Und dafür gibt es wiederum andere Dinge, die mir leichter fallen, die ihm sehr, sehr schwer fallen. Und da ist es halt in dem Fall so, dass es dahingehend so nutzt, dass auch der Leiter vom Forschungsinstitut, als er jetzt – ich glaube, das war der Landeswettbewerb, wo er dann da war, wo er gesagt hat, Jason wird das in jedem Fall gewinnen. Die einzige Hürde, die es gibt, ist, dass die Jury verstehen muss, was er vorhat und was er dort macht, weil er mit dem nächsten Schritt, den er geht, sich dann in den Bereich der Grundlagenforschung begibt insgesamt. Und ich habe keine Ahnung, was er da tut. Er hat mir das 26 Mal erklärt, aber ich könnte es jetzt nicht wiedergeben. Aber es fällt dann schon auf, wenn du dann siehst, er darf ja bei Jugendforscht noch gar nicht mitmachen. Das darf er erst ab dem nächsten Jahr, glaube ich.
Nächstes Jahr bin ich ja bei diesem Wettbewerb in China. Übernächstes Jahr dann.
Ja, sodass er dort eigentlich in der Gruppe ist, wo dann Schüler experimentieren. Da geht es dann, ich habe Kristalle gezüchtet oder dies und dies. Und die haben halt auch alle was zu zeigen. Und dann gehst du da so rum und sagst, oh cool, das verstehe ich, das ist toll. Und dann stehst du da bei deinem Sohn und der sagt dann, ja, das ergode im Theorien, das ist so und so.
Aber ich hatte auch was zu zeigen.
Ja, aber das war etwas, was ich nicht greifen konnte und auch sichtbar niemand anders.
Ich wette, ich hatte mehr Messdaten als alle anderen in meiner Kategorie zusammen.
Ja, zweifelsohne. Aber man hat es halt auch am Publikumsverkehr gesehen. Da sind ganz, ganz viele Angehörige von anderen, die sind dann so vorbei und sind dann weitergegangen. Die blieben dann doch lieber beim GPS-gesteuerten Lego-Meh-Roboter stehen. Wo die Leute sagen, ah ok, der meht den Rasen. Klasse, super, verstehe ich. Die, die dann bei ihm stehen blieben, wenn ich dann so zugehört habe, das war dann so die Generation 50, 60 plus, die dann völlig verzweifelt davor stand und sagen, ja das kann der nicht alleine gemacht haben. Das ist wieder so einer, dem sein Vater ist, Professor und so weiter und so weiter. Und ich stand so dahinter, ich habe es genüsslich angehört. Und dann haben sie ihn angesprochen und dann hat er halt dann mal so frei so erklärt. Und dann sagten sie, ja aber ist das nicht so? Und dann sagt er, nein, das ist eigentlich so. Und das ist, ah ja, so habe ich das noch gar nicht gesehen. Also die standen nach dem Gespräch dann plötzlich da und dachten so, was zur Hölle ist hier los insgesamt? Und er hat da halt einfach ein ganz, ganz tiefes Detailinteresse, aber es ist halt gepaart mit dem, dass es ihm einfacher fährt, auch dass es wirklich für ihn auch sehr, sehr viel Arbeit ist. Also er liest sehr, sehr viel, er recherchiert sehr, sehr viel, er schaut sich heute Nacht dann auf YouTube irgendwelche, morgen Abend muss er um 22 Uhr im Forschungszentrum sein, weil es dann vom Planetarium aus eine spezielle Konstellation gibt, die er sich anschauen will etc. Also er nimmt dann auch alles mit.
Aber das kann sein, im schlimmsten Fall muss ich da übernachten, weil der letzte Bus zurück nach Hause fährt bei uns relativ kurz, oder ich weiß gar nicht, wann fährt der letzte Bus? Kurz vor 11, genau. Und es könnte sein, dass ich den nicht schaffe, und dann muss ich entweder zu meinem Opa fahren, da fahren noch länger Züge hin, oder wenn das nicht geht, muss ich da übernachten.
Weil eben der Umweltschutz für dich eine so hohe Bedeutung hat, dass nur mit öffentlichem Nahverkehr gereist werden soll und so weiter.
In abstrosen Umfang?
Nein, das ist nicht abstrus. Das ist angemessen.
Tristan, kannst du selber sagen, was dich da antreibt, wenn du an so ein Forschungsprojekt setzt? Ist es ein langfristiges Ziel, das du dir gesetzt hast, oder ist es vielleicht auch das Feedback, das du dafür bekommst, und die Achtung und die Wahrnehmung der anderen, wie jetzt zum Beispiel der Menschen, die dann da bei einer Ausstellung stehen und ganz begeistert sind von deinem Wissen und sich mit dir darüber unterhalten? Was treibt dich da an?
Erstens will ich natürlich die Wissenschaft damit voranbringen. Ich will neue Erkenntnisse gewinnen. Das habe ich auch jetzt schon gemacht. Der Bereich des Ergodenstheorien ist jetzt weiter als bevor ich mit diesen Forschungen angefangen habe. Da sind neue Erkenntnisse dazugekommen. Zweitens macht es natürlich auch einfach Riesenspaß. Es ist eigentlich perfekt. Man bringt die Sachen damit voran. Man kann sich Stunden damit beschäftigen. Ich könnte wirklich Tage damit beschäftigen, ohne zu schlafen. Mir würde nicht langweilig werden. Weil es ist einfach so tief. Ich glaube, selbst wenn ich das Forschungsgebiet jetzt noch 50 Jahre beibehalte, werde ich in 50 Jahren immer noch weiter forschen können. Und ich werde immer noch Dinge entdecken, die ich noch nicht weiß. Und es gibt halt einfach schon einen Antrieb.
In einem Interview oder in einem Artikel über euch stand ein Satz, also das ist jetzt ein Zitat. Ein Arzt bestätigte die Autismusdiagnose. Er sagte außerdem, es werde viele Dinge geben, die Jason nicht erreichen kann. Seitdem leben Jason und seine Familie gegen diesen Satz an. Und dann kommt ein Zitat von dir, Mirko. Autisten leiden nicht unter Autismus, sie leiden nur unter dem rücksichtslosen Umgang mit ihnen. Und ich glaube, dieses Nicht-Leiden als Betroffener, das haben wir jetzt gerade sehr gut verdeutlicht bekommen. Du hast einen irren Spaß an Dingen. Du kannst Dinge, die wir nicht schaffen würden, wenn wir uns ein Leben lang damit beschäftigen würden. Jetzt würde mich der Faktor des Umgangs der Außenwelt mit Autisten interessieren. Was meinst du damit, Mirko, wenn du schreibst rücksichtsloser Umgang?
Ja, würde ich heute den Satz gar nicht mehr so sagen. Ich würde ihn eher so sagen, nicht so pauschalisiert sagen, Autisten leiden nicht, sondern dass nur Autisten selbst darüber zu entscheiden haben, über welche Teile, Aspekte ihres Autismus ist, sie leiden oder nicht. Das war vielleicht damals die gekürzte Variante insgesamt. Aber es ist halt schon so, dass ich einerseits natürlich habe ich das Verständnis und den Background und das Know-how, was ist bei meinem Sohn gegebenenfalls dann doch ein bisschen anders vom Betriebssystem, wie es hier oft so schön verglichen wird, so ein bisschen. Was aber dann doch so komplex ist, dass ich das nicht jedem Tag täglich, zehnmal am Tag in unterschiedlichsten Situationen sagen kann, hören Sie zu, das, was Sie jetzt hier gerade erleben, hängt damit, damit, damit zusammen. Man wird halt einfach sehr, sehr schnell müde gegebenenfalls, das zu erklären. Aber es ist ja erstmal völlig nachvollziehbar, dass wenn man in einer Straßenbahn sitzt und Jason anfängt einen Feuerwehr-Alarmsignal nach zu singen oder ganz hoch zu quiken und er das eine Station macht, zwei Stationen, drei Stationen macht, dann ist es ja erstmal nachvollziehbar, dass der ein oder andere Mitfahrende vielleicht sagt, hm, finde ich schon nicht so gut, dass sie als Vater dort jetzt nicht eingreifen, gegebenenfalls.
Er hat ja gar nicht das Recht einzugreifen.
Ja, aber das wissen ja Außenstehende nicht.
Das wissen ja Außenstehende in dem Fall nicht so. Und in dem Moment gibt es dann halt a, die Möglichkeit, den Leuten sehr langwierig zu erklären, dass ich ihn daran jetzt definitiv nicht hindern kann, dass ich, egal welchen Ansatz ich dort wähle, dass ich es damit gegebenenfalls nur verschlimmere oder die Situation verlängere, weil vielleicht hat er sich vorgenommen, vier am Stück Feuerwehralarm zu singen. Wenn ich ihn bei Station drei unterbreche, dann fängt er an der nächsten Station von vorn an, dann sind es noch mal vier Stationen. Also man weiß nie konkret, was ist dort jetzt…
Also das bedeutet, auf deren Rücken das Gewicht des Patriarchats liegt.
Ja, ich würde es erstmal so sehen, ich verstehe wie gesagt dort deinen Blickwinkel, aber ich sehe es halt schon auch so, dass wenn man sich irgendwo in einer Gesellschaft bewegt, mein Verhalten ja auch, so wie du sagst, freies Recht auf Selbstbestimmung, solange es nur dich betrifft, so betrifft es ja dann, wenn du den Feuerwehralarm über fünf Stationen in der S-Bahn machst, auch andere.
Ja, aber der letzte, der dich betrifft, der bist aber du. Das bedeutet, du hast auf gar keinen Fall das Recht, da reinzugreifen. Wenn es die Leute stört, dann müssen sie auf mich zugehen.
Ja, und da haben wir halt schon wieder einen klassischen Unterschied, ein bisschen in der Differenzierung, dass ich eigentlich mich da als die Brücke sehe, dass ich sage, da sieht eine Gesellschaft vielleicht mich als Vater in der Verantwortung, dort regulierend in welcher Form auch einzugreifen oder halt umgekehrt, du mich vielleicht auch in der Verantwortung, dass du sagst, ich mach jetzt meinen Alarm, du hast den jetzt zu erklären. Ich sitze halt dazwischen und weiß eigentlich eine ganze Zeit lang nicht, was mache ich denn jetzt? Und irgendwann habe ich halt damit aufgehört, überhaupt irgendwas zu machen, sondern habe es einfach laufen lassen, weil ich wusste, das ist eigentlich die Situation, wie es am schnellsten endet. Und es ist für ihn tendenziell mit keinen Unannehmlichkeiten verbunden, die es vielleicht noch schlimmer oder noch problematischer machen insgesamt. Und die Gesellschaft insgesamt, das meine ich damit, wenn ich dann aufkläre oder wenn ich eine Situation kläre und dann als Reaktion kommt, ja, da muss der Junge mal dies oder da muss der Junge mal das. Nein, der muss gar nichts. Es würde nie jemand auf die Idee kommen, zu einem blinden Jungen zu sehen, jetzt liest du mal die Zeitung, streng dich halt mal an. Auf die Idee würde nie jemand kommen. Bei Autismus ist es aber halt nun mal so und diese enorme Diskrepanz, da sitzt ein Junge, der erklärt dir die Chaosforschung von A bis Z und im nächsten Moment macht er etwas, wo du es nicht verhindern kannst, wo du sagst, das passt halt einfach nicht zusammen oder er versteht das nicht gegebenenfalls, weil es halt eine unsichtbare Behinderung ist insgesamt. Du siehst halt nie den Wind selbst, du siehst halt nur die teilweise leicht schwingenden Zweige oder halt auch mal die heftigen Auswirkungen eines Orkans, dass hier die Äste durch die Gegend brechen oder so. Und diese ganze Bandbreite, die musst du versuchen im Alltag, sprich meine Frau damals, mit allem, was dort passieren kann, durchreglementiert vom Moment des Aufstehens der Weg zum Kindergarten. Es gab einen ganz strengen Weg, den wir einzuhalten haben, um die Mülltonne drumherum etc. bis wir das gecheckt haben, dass der komplette Tag gelaufen war bei ihm, wenn wir den Weg nicht eingehalten haben. Das hat halt auch ein paar Monate gedauert, weil du auf die Idee ja gar nicht kommst. Und so gibt es halt ganz, ganz viele Dinge, wo ich sage, die Gesellschaft selbst hat dann zu wenig Verständnis, wenn es dann irgendwo auch aufgeklärt ist insgesamt, weil es halt unsichtbar ist, weil die Leute sagen, ja, das kann ja nicht sein. Also wir haben das auch bei Medienterminen ganz, ganz häufig erlebt, dass ich dann in dem Briefing angegeben habe, hey, wenn die auch gefragt haben, ich sage, Mensch, Jason gibt halt nicht so gerne die Hand. Wenn sie ihm hingereicht wird, wägt der aber mittlerweile ab und sagt, bevor ich jetzt erklärt habe, warum ich keinen Bock habe, dann trage ich es dann lieber in dem Moment. Aber es ist halt schon wieder der erste kleine Stresspunkt, und wir haben es aber einen Termin erlebt, dass ein Journalist oder eine Journalistin es genau auf diese Situation angelegt hat. Also dass ich wirklich gesagt habe, es wurde gefragt, worauf müssen wir achten, dann habe ich die Situation genannt, worauf zu achten ist, und es wurden genau diese Situationen provoziert, um gegebenenfalls die Reaktion zu erzeugen. Weil das ja schon etwas ist, das war es auch sehr, sehr häufig. Und vielleicht auch einer, Jason, sagt ja, das Buch ist von meiner Seite aus voller Fehler. Wenn es einen Fehler gibt, den ich im Buch schreibe, dann schreibe ich sehr oft von Wutausbrüchen oder so. Wut ist eigentlich immer ein Treiber, um irgendwas zu bekommen, gegebenenfalls um seinen Willen durchzusetzen oder so. Das ist eigentlich falsch, weil es eigentlich immer nur eine Reaktion ist bei Jason auf etwas, was eigentlich geklärt ist, wie es sein muss, und es ist dann anders. Das ist dann der Moment, wo es wirklich zur Eskalation kommt, zu diesen sogenannten Overloads. Die sehen aus wie Wutausbrüche, aber haben halt nichts miteinander zu tun, weil dieser Wutausbruch ist beendet. Der steht ja nicht stampfend vorm Spielzeugregal. Ich sage, ich will die Hängeschaukel haben und ich kauf die Hängeschaukel, und dann ist das Problem gelöst. Sondern es ist die Reaktion auf eine Situation, die anders vorgegeben ist, als sie da war und die sich auch nicht mehr lösen lässt. Die also dann quasi erst sehr, sehr nachhaltig oder sehr, sehr viel später zu einer gewissen beruhigten Situation führt.
Also im Buch vergleichst du das in einem Kapitel mit Löffeln, dass jeder Mensch eine gewisse Zahl an Löffeln hat, mit denen er Eindrücke, Erlebnisse verarbeiten kann pro Tag. Und vergleichst es dann damit, dass Jason in Situationen, in denen wir, wir sitzen jetzt gerade am Tisch und für mich kostet das Moderieren hier einen Löffel Aufwand. Und es könnte jetzt aber so sein – Jason, du darfst mich sehr gerne korrigieren – dass für dich aber gerade hier draußen die Bewegung der Bäume ist schon ein Eindruck für einen Löffel. Und du guckst dir das Zimmer ganz genau und ich habe schon total Angst, wie gut oder schlecht ich hier aufgeräumt habe. Das könnte noch ein Löffel sein und vielleicht hätten wir hier noch eine tickende Uhr. Die würdest du noch wahrnehmen und das wäre dann vielleicht ein weiterer. So hatte ich es verstanden, ist das so ungefähr eine Beschreibung, mit der du leben kannst. Und dann sind eben deine Löffel schneller weg. Und am Ende des Tages, der vielleicht dann bei dir, könnte halt dann um 12 Uhr Mittag sein, ist einfach keine Kraft mehr da, mit all diesen Eindrücken auszukommen. Und dann ist es ja klar, dass weder du etwas tun kannst, Mirko, als noch, dass du wirklich etwas tun kannst, weil das ist halt dann einfach so. Das kennt man selber von sich ja auch, dass man so völlig fertig mit allem ist. Und also ich habe dieses Gefühl auch immer wieder als Alleinerziehender Selbstständiger, dass ich das Gefühl habe, er ist jetzt zu viel, das geht einfach nicht weiter. Aber ich habe dann noch Möglichkeiten, aus dieser Situation wieder rauszukommen. Und die fehlen dann vielleicht halt an der Stelle für Jason.
Und die Logik dessen, was einen fordert, ist halt etwas, was komplett abweicht. Also während er vielleicht den Löffel wirklich braucht, um zwei Parallelgeräusche irgendwie, die sich längere Zeit begleiten, zu verkraften, ist es etwas, dass er, als wir Osteuropa-Tour unterwegs waren, 8, 5 Stunden mit einem 10-Kilo-Rucksack durch die Pampa rennt und läuft und schwitzt, während ich körperlich, also wo wirklich über reinen Willen er Dinge leistet, wo ich sage, das passt nicht ins Verhältnis. Und ich ihn dann die ganze Zeit schonen will und er sagt, nee, das ist etwas, was mir Spaß und Freude bereitet. Also die Relationen, die sind dann halt nicht immer recht logisch aufgebaut. Banalitäten können vielleicht zwei, drei Löffel kosten. Und Dinge, die uns vielleicht richtig anstrengen würden, ist etwas, was ja leichter wegsteckt.
Und was würdet ihr beide euch jetzt wünschen, was geschehen müsste, damit eben genau diese Lebenswelt von Autisten, die sich ja dann auch von Autist zu Autist ja auch nochmal unterscheidet, dass da ein höheres Verständnis für herrscht. Was müsste dafür passieren?
Also einer der ersten Schritte wäre – und das ist aber auch gleichzeitig wahrscheinlich der unrealistischste – dass Autismus, Autist oder auch als Adjektiv autistisch nicht grundlegend als negative Metapher in den Medien herhalten muss. Also jetzt glaube ich gestern wieder ein großer Beitrag. Es vergeht eigentlich keine Zeit, wo nicht irgendwie bei Trump, sei es Merkel oder was auch immer, oder die Koalitionsverhandlungen, die FAZ titelt ganz groß das Ringen der Autisten, weil sie sich halt nicht entscheiden können oder so. Es wird eigentlich immer so als Negativmetapher. Das ist etwas, was einem gar nicht so auffällt im Normalfall. Aber selbst in den aktuellen Büchern über Trump, es gibt kein einziges, wo er nicht mit einem autistischen Verhalten beschrieben wird. Und es ist halt nicht so, dass ich das so negativ sehe. Ich kann den Ansatz in Teilen nachvollziehen, aber es ist halt extrem, extrem blöd.
Es ist unangebracht. Es ist so wie, wenn Menschen das Wort behindert als Schimpfwort verwenden. Und dafür muss man ein Bewusstsein schaffen und auch selbst sehr darauf achten, dass auch man in einem eigenen Sprachgebrauch so etwas nicht macht.
Ja, und dazu gibt es ja noch den Betroffenen quasi eine Ausrede. Im Fall von Trump oder wie auch immer zu sagen, naja, der kann ja vielleicht nichts dafür, weil das ist ja eine Behinderung oder so. Also von beiden Seiten eigentlich Unsinn.
Wenn man das aber dann halt realistisch betrachtet, dann ist es da, glaube ich, gerade in der aktuellen gesellschaftlichen Lage ein sehr, sehr, sehr langer Weg. Wenn ich parallel dazu jetzt überlege, wie oft ich selber vielleicht im Alter von 16, 17, 18 als aktiver Kreisklassen-C-Fußballer irgendwie den Schiri-Blinde-Sau genannt habe, ganz selbstverständlich gegebenenfalls. Und wenn mir dann den Abend jemand gesagt hat, ja du hör mal zu, also das sagt man nicht, weil und so weiter, dann hätte ich gesagt, was willst du eigentlich von mir oder so. Da ist ja auch so ein Bewusstsein, muss ja auch entstehen. Bei mir hat es halt etwas länger gedauert. Und so glaube ich halt auch, wenn man das dann nochmal runterbricht auf einzelne kleine Segmente des Themas Behinderung oder eigentlich alles, was Minderheiten oder Diskriminierung angeht, das ist, halte ich für relativ unrealistisch, dass wir dort große Sprünge in den nächsten Jahren werden. Wir richten uns eher darauf ein, dass es problematischer und schlimmer wird noch.
Ja, ihr habt mal eine Podcastfolge gemacht im Radio Rebell. Das ist euer Podcast, die hieß, Zitat, der Scheißautist und sein Loserdate. Ich kanns auch sagen, wenn ich dich nicht mehr erinnere.
Ja, bitte, bitte, bitte.
Das war Teil drei eurer drei Folgen, die ihr zur Buchveröffentlichung gemacht habt. Und im dritten Teil ging es dann um die Medientermine, die ihr hattet und um Facebook-Kommentare unter einem Video, das ich glaube der Hessische Rundfunk aus einem Interview von euch herausgeschnitten hat. Und dann habt ihr den sieben dümmsten Kommentatoren – waren alles Männer, deswegen kann ich das Kommentatorinnen weglassen – den habt ihr dann im Podcast geantwortet. Aber da wurde eben schon sehr deutlich, es gab auch viele positive Reaktionen, aber eben gerade in dieser Sphäre des Internets, also eben ohne einen persönlichen Kontakt, da gibt es auch Kommentare, da wäre jetzt Unverständnis ein Euphemismus dafür, wie die sich äußern, sondern deutlichst unter der Gürtellinie. Und wie kann man dem begegnen? Muss man das wegignorieren? Sollte man sich darüber lustig machen? Muss man da in die Aufklärungsarbeit gehen?
Also da gibt es ja dann aus meiner Warte heraus immer erstmal zwei Blickwinkel. Wie gehe ich selber damit um? Und in welchem Umfang ist das etwas, wo ich meinen Sohn mit einbinden darf, mit einbinden soll oder auf gar keinen Fall mit einbinden sollte oder darf?
Ich muss überall mit einbinden.
Das weiß ich. Das macht es im Umgang mit Jason natürlich schwierig. Es war gerade im Fall der Kommentare, was den Ausschnitt aus dem Auftritt beim Hessischen Rundfunk angeht, halt doppelt ärgerlich. Das war ein 12-Minuten-Auftritt und es wurde eigentlich runtergebrochen. Wir sind eingeladen worden von Emre Can zu einem Spiel des FC Liverpool. Und er kümmert sich um alles und alles ist prima, alles toll. Und dann ist die Mats fertig und Jason fragt als erstes, machen die einen Kreis? Und das ist eigentlich das Hauptsegment, das übrig geblieben ist. Was natürlich, wenn ich nur das sehe, ohne den ganzen Vorlauf, erstmal auch etwas ist, wo ich sagen würde, wie kann das denn sein, der wird eingeladen von Emre Can. Also ich habe auch dort wieder ein gewisses Verständnis.
Ja genau, es gibt eben eine Erwartungshaltung. Die Erwartungshaltung wäre gewesen, dass du vor Freude völlig ausrastend durchs Studio springst und sagst, Liverpool, toller Verein, Emre Can, schon immer mein Lieblingsspieler. Ich habe schon früher in Liverpool wettvorscht geschlafen. Danke, danke, danke, danke auch an den hessischen Rundfunk dafür. Deine erste Reaktion war eben einfach, weil Emre Can aus der Mats rausging mit, naja, und dann wirst du ja sicher Liverpool-Fan. Und deine erste Frage war, ja, machen die den Kreis? Weil dann ist für dich klar, dann wäre ich ja einfach nicht Liverpool-Fan.
Der Beitrag, also der Beitrag selbst, der lief dann auch, das war auch relativ unproblematisch, der ist dann halt noch mal separiert worden, in Ausständen von der Sportschau auf der Facebook-Seite. Und dann ist der eigentlich, ich glaub, der ist jetzt irgendwie weit über eine Million aufrufe, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, ist also quasi dann ja auch etwas, wo du dann automatisch über die Menge oder über die Reichweite hast, hast du dann immer die Situation, egal was dort gegebenfalls geäußert würde, wo du dann immer auch dumme Kommentare dabei hast. Und wir haben halt dann, meine Frau und ich, meine Frau hat das sehr, sehr belastet, also die konnte damit so am Anfang so gar nicht umgehen. Ich hab das etwas entspannter gesehen, weil ich das auch von anderen Facebook-Posts von uns schon kannte, die ich aber dann immer sofort auf Verbergen setze, dass die gar keiner so groß mitbekommt. Dadurch kannte ich das schon und ich hab das halt auch nicht als, ich guck mir dann auch solche Accounts immer sehr, sehr gerne dann schon durchaus nochmal an. Und dann ist es schon etwas, wo du dann auch sagst, okay, das ist sinnlos, da kannst du jetzt gar nichts machen. Und als Jason dann darauf aufgenommen hat, was ist da und wie ist das, haben wir die dann halt aber mit zum Anlass genommen, dass wir dann darüber wirklich auch sprechen, dass ihm das bewusst ist. Ich meine, egal was er in der Vergangenheit gemacht hat, er geht ins Forschungszentrum, dann kommt er auf irgendwelche, räumt er da irgendwelche Preise ab, Grimme Online Award, davor Goldene Blogger. Alles, was er tut, ist immer etwas, wo hey, hey, toll, super, prima etc. Es gibt halt auch die andere Seite, wo ich dann schon sage, die werde ich ihm ja nicht für sein restliches Leben lang verheimlichen können.
Wollt er doch nicht.
Weiß ich. Und habe dann schon das so gesehen, dass ich gesagt habe, er ist dort durchaus in der Reife, wo ich ihm zutraue, damit umzugehen, sodass wir gesagt haben, okay, wir nehmen jetzt die Kommentare, besprechen die und haben dann ab zum Abschluss besprochen, dass wir die dann auch mit in die Podcast-Folge aufnehmen. Weil neben diesem Feedback ja auch auf ganz vielen anderen Wegen, als Blogkommentar oder halt dann auch als E-Mail gegebenenfalls durchaus mal Rückmeldung kommen, die halt nicht immer nur hey, alles ist toll, alles ist super, alles ist prima. Sondern das ist schon so, dass es dort auch durchaus entweder kritisches Feedback gibt, was auch vollkommen in Ordnung ist, aber halt auch durchaus sehr, sehr hässliches insgesamt. Du gehst halt mit beiden identisch um, das ist so ein bisschen das Problem.
Nein, das stimmt nicht. Über hässliches Feedback reg ich mich nicht auf, über kritisches schon.
Wie sehr hängt das damit zusammen, dass ihr euch auch politisch klar positioniert habt, gegen Diskriminierung, gegen Nazis sehr aktiv und laut da unterwegs seid?
Also ich glaube zumindest, dass das der Zeitpunkt war, wo es eskaliert ist, obwohl das keine bewusste Wir-Politisieren-uns-jetzt-Entscheidung war. Wir waren bei der ersten Lesung. Es war damals kurz davor, war dieser Vorfall zwischen dem SV Babelsberg und Energie Cottbus. Ich hatte bei der ersten Lesung das Nazis-raus-aus-den-Stadion-T-Shirt an. Und der Jochen bzw. Jochens Freundin und Lebensgefährtin ist Fotografin und hat uns gesagt, hey, wisst ihr was, ihr habt heute eure erste Lesung, ich mach euch ein paar Bilder davon, dann habt ihr die als Erinnerung und dann könnt ihr die gegebenenfalls bei den nächsten Lesungen für die Ankündigung nutzen. Und dann ist es eigentlich erst eskaliert, als wir das dann gegebenenfalls, ich glaube, das erste war gar kein Facebook-Post, sondern das erste war in der Tageszeitung, bei einer Lesung in Kassel. In Kassel gibt es halt nichts. Also wenn da keine Dokumente da ist, ist das ein – da ist halt nichts. Der Herkules noch, aber ansonsten kennt man da nichts. Sodass wir dort sehr, sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit bekommen haben. Und da war auch das Bild zu sehen. Und wir sind dann halt über Tage mit E-Mails malträtiert worden, wo ich schon sage, wow, das hatte dann schon eine Qualität, die mir das erste Mal auch eine Form von Angst machte insgesamt. Ja, doch, das schon.
Also ältere Reaktionen auf diese Kommentare habe ich mir dann auch ein Nazis-Raus-T-Shirt gekauft.
Das hilft dir nur wenig, wenn da von den Kameraden mal einer vor der Tür steht.
Das steht ja wahrscheinlich in diesen E-Mails. Das habe ich ja in viel, viel kleineren Umfang. Aber da hat er auch schon durchaus zwei, drei E-Mails im Postangang, wo dann drin steht, wenn es um mich geht, bin ich da auch schmerzbefreiter. Aber wenn dann drin steht, wäre schon schade, wenn deinem Kindern was passiert. Das löst in dir einen Reflex aus, der nicht gut ist.
Ich sehe das alles relativ entspannt.
Ja, das ist auch vollkommen okay. Ich finde es auch gut, wie du damit umgehst. Da kannst du dich sehr, sehr glücklich schätzen. Aber es ist genauso, wie Max sagt, ich habe da wenig Angst, dass dort Leute vor der Tür stehen und mir an die Wäsche wollen oder so. Aber wenn sie drohen und gleichzeitig natürlich auch immer nachvollziehbar in Anführungszeichen kluge Argumente bringen und sagen, hey, wie praktisch das eure Lesereisen-Termine, dass man weiß, wann man euch wo findet etc. Dann ist das natürlich erstmal etwas, wo du lernen musst, mit dieser Sorge, mit dieser Angst insgesamt umzugehen.
Aber der schlechteste Umgang ist darauf, es sich zurückzuziehen.
Ja, aber es ist trotzdem etwas, wo man nicht so pauschal drüber geht. Aber das war sicherlich, glaube ich, so ein bisschen der Startpunkt, wo wir das erste Mal damit so intensiv konfrontiert wurden. Und dann hat sich das eigentlich immer mal wiederholt, sei es dann auch offener als Facebook-Kommentar etc. Und es sind dann halt schon Aussagen, die sich vom Gruseligkeitsfaktor steigern. Ich habe ganz, ganz viel davon archiviert. Wenn du auf Facebook kommentarierst, siehst du den Arbeitgeber, den Klarnamen etc. Wo du sagst, meine Güte, das kann ja nicht dein Ernst sein. Hast du nicht mal einen Arbeitgeber angeschrieben? Nee, noch nicht. Aber es sind halt auch Leute dabei, die uns gegebenenfalls schon sehr lange verfolgten, wo es dann völlig eskaliert ist wegen diesem T-Shirt und der dann schon klaren Positionierung, wo du dann, wenn du den gesamten Messenger-Verlauf siehst, dann erst so, hey, kommt doch mal nach X, hier ist so toll und hier ist so cool und so weiter. Und dann die nächste so links-grün-versüftete Drecksau, ich schneide dir die Kehle durch. Das ist der selbe. Du kannst, wenn du den gesamten Verlauf als Bildchen-Event, das ist ein Kunstwerk. Das kannst du dir nicht, das kannst du dir nicht ausdenken. Das weiß ich nicht, wie man darauf kommt.
Na ja, meine Theorie dazu ist, in so ganz begrenzten Umfang habe ich das auch schon erlebt. Meine Theorie dazu ist, die Leute entwickeln eine Bindung zu dir, auch eine Zuneigung zu dir. Die mögen das, was du machst, eben dann bei euch eben eure Touren, eure Blogs drüber. Und hier ist es so, sie hören dir gerne übers Fußball sprechen zu. Und dann positioniert sich dieser jemand politisch in eine Richtung, die du absolut verabscheust. Und dann kommen sie zuerst mit dem Argument, halt doch bitte die Politik aus deinem Podcast raus. Da kann man dann sehr, sehr schnell darauf antworten, kann sagen, danke, nein, dann ist das falsch für dich. Und dann kommt aber da, glaube ich, so eine enttäuschte Wut zu Gange. Du bist auch einer von denen, die ich überhaupt besteigen kann.
Dann säubert man dadurch ja ein bisschen seinen Fankreis durch solche Aussagen.
Auf der anderen Seite hören dir irgendwann, wenn dir nur Leute zuhören, die dir in allem zustimmen, dann brauchst du dich tatsächlich nicht mehr politisch auszuhören.
Na gut, es gibt ja einen Unterschied zwischen es hören dir nur Leute zu, die dir zustimmen und es hören dir irgendwelche Nazis zu. Da muss man ja auch schon unterscheiden.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall ein Thema, dem wir eine Zeit lang ein gewisses Maß an Raum geben mussten und dann aber irgendwann gesagt haben, ne, also eine Zeit lang war es wirklich so, dass ich auf jeden Kommentar geantwortet habe, auch völlig die Nerven verbracht habe. Ja, Jason dann noch mit eingestiegen ist, dann stieg der nächste wieder ein. Es kamen dann die nächsten Rückmeldungen von Leuten, die uns wohlgesonnen sind, die dann sagten, also ich mag das ja und ihr macht das alles toll, aber dass ihr da auf jeden Scheiß reagieren müsst, auf Facebook, das nervt mich einfach so, wo ich gesagt habe. Es ist halt auch was anderes, wenn ich irgendwo eine Aussage von Storch, Weidel, Co. wie sie alle heißen, sehe, dann kann ich sie stehen lassen dort, dann kann ich entscheiden, packe ich da was als Gegenkommentar drunter, weil ich es nicht unwidersprochen stehen lassen will. Eigentlich wenn, dann nur noch so meistens.
Ich mache es dann immer so, dass ich es zitiere, mache ich mittlerweile nicht mehr, weil das der erste Retweet sieht, ich mache mal einen Screenshot und schreibe dann den Kommentar.
Ja, aber auch das ist irgendwann gut. Aber das würde jetzt sehr, sehr weit führen. Und jetzt ist es halt eigentlich so, dass ich da gar nicht mehr drauf reagiere oder halt wirklich sage, komm ich packe das sofort auf Verbergen, weil halt auch blockieren so eine Sache ist schwierig.
Blockiere oft? Ich mache es oft immer so, dass ich mich in Diskussionen einmische und danach alle anderen Diskussionspartner blockiere.
Ja, also du landest da halt schnell so auf so Trophäenlisten oder so, wo die sich dann freuen, dass du sie geblockt hast. Dann kommt der nächste, warum hast du den geblockt? Also das ist so ein...
Ich kann Juden sehr empfehlen. Das ist besser. Weil wenn du den falschen Troll blockst, dann schmeißt er einen russischen Bot an und dann hast du auf einmal 250 Follower, die dich zuspammen unter jedem deiner Tweets mit entsprechender Bewertigung.
Ich habe einmal jemanden gemeldet, der wurde gesperrt und dann habe ich von einer Meldung, die ich von Twitter bekommen habe, der ist jetzt gesperrt, habe einen Screenshot gemacht mit dem Kommentar und shit. Und den Tag danach war mein ganzer Blog voll mit Viren.
Geht schnell. Das ist nicht hilfreich. Wir nutzen seitdem das Mute-Chain, die Chrome-Erweiterung. Ich glaube, ich habe knapp 10.000 Accounts gemute. Was das angeht, ist massiv früher eingegehrt.
Überlege, ob ich das mache mit meinem Account.
Das kannst du ja dann selber entscheiden. Bei Facebook wiederum ist es so, dass wir dort, wenn dort Kommentare sind, da hält es sich auch in Grenzen.
Bei Facebook müssen wir uns ja auf eine Strategie einigen, weil da haben wir ja nur einen gemeinsamen Account.
Da kannst du ja dann deine Strategie fahren. Sobald du den Blog übernommen hast, ist das ja auch deine Seite. Dann kannst du damit machen, was du willst. Bis dahin ist es so, dass ich dort wirklich nur noch verberge und stehen lasse und fertig. Das ist wahrscheinlich das Nächste. Überzeugen tust du von denen sowieso keinen.
Ja, das ist allerdings wahr. Und steht diese antidiskriminierende Haltung auch im Kriterienkatalog für Fußballvereine, von denen du Fan werden könntest in der Theorie?
Ein Ausschlusskriterium ist es nur, wenn sie sich politisch deutlich schlecht positionieren. Wenn sie sich politisch deutlich gut positionieren, dann ist das auch ein Vorteil, etwas, was sehr gut ist. Aber es ist kein grundsätzliches Kriterium, dass man sagt, er muss sich so positionieren. Ein Verein, der sich sogar dagegen positioniert, der ist natürlich raus.
Wenn wir jetzt beim Thema Social Media sind und du inzwischen sehr aktiv bist mit deinem eigenen Twitter-Account – vor allem bei Twitter sieht man sehr viel von dir – unterscheidet sich für dich der Umgang mit Menschen im Vergleich von Social Media zum echten Leben?
Eigentlich gar nicht. Das einzige Gute an Social Media ist, dass man mehr Reichweite hat und mehr Leute auf einmal mit einer Botschaft überliefern kann. Aber eigentlich schreibe ich auf Twitter das selbe, was ich im Podcast sage oder was ich anderen Leuten auf der Lesung sage. Da gibt es eigentlich keinen Unterschied.
Interessant. Das hätte ich jetzt so gar nicht erwartet. Woher kommt dann der Ehrgeiz, sich da zum Teil auch bewusst reinzustürzen? Du hast im Podcast erzählt, dass du dir manchmal auch Nazi-Hashtags suchst und dann einfach mal schnell da ein paar Leute durchmeldest und dann ja auch viele Accounts zum Sperren bekommst. Woher nimmst du dafür dann die Motivation?
Also ich mach das jetzt nicht so, dass ich mir dafür gezielt Zeit nehme oder so. Sondern wenn ich am Computer sitze und mittlerweile geht das fast gar nicht mehr. Deswegen melde ich mittlerweile auch weniger als vorher. Aber sag ich mal so vor zwei Jahren, da war das noch manchmal so, dass ich einfach mal Zeit hatte am Computer und eigentlich da so überlegen konnte, was ich dann mache. Und dann habe ich es tatsächlich manchmal so gemacht, dass ich mir gezielte Hashtags rausgesucht habe, guckte, wie kann man dort Leute – ich habe nicht einfach durchgemeldet oder was darunter geschrieben. Ich habe wirklich teilweise Leute, Accounts verfolgt. Also ich bin denen nicht gefolgt, aber ich habe sie halt verfolgt durch gewisse Hashtags und so. Ich habe manchmal Monate darauf gewartet, dass sie sich irgendwas leisten, was wirklich gegen die Twitterregeln verstößt. Ich konnte die Twitterregeln auswendig zu dem Zeitpunkt. Ich habe wirklich einmal darauf gewartet und habe gesagt, ok, irgendwann werden die sich sowas leisten. Das ist nur eine Frage der Zeit. Bei den meisten Accounts war dann irgendwann so, und ich würde sagen, ich habe bis jetzt so ungefähr 100 Accounts gemeldet, und von denen sind so 30, 40 gesperrt worden.
Das passt auch schon einiges über die Policy von Twitter aus, aber damit haben wir, denke ich, alle hier schon Erfahrungen gemacht. Also, wir haben eine Idee, einen Verein zu suchen, so ging alles los. Dann hatten wir das Blog und Social Media als Begleitfaktoren. Wir kamen dann irgendwann zu dem Buch, die Preise prasselten herein bis auf einen Skandal, den Skandal von Nürnberg. Ok, also die ist quasi nicht…
Deutschland-Fußball-Kultur-Preise auch. Und der ist das Fußballbuch des Jahres. Aber die erste Gala…
Ach so, du meinst…
Das war auch ein Skandal.
Das hast du aber fast gar nicht mitbekommen.
Ja, das habe ich mitbekommen.
Da ging es beim deutschen Fußball-Kulturpreis, da war das Blog mal nominiert vor fünf Jahren oder so.
Und ich war bei der Gala nicht dabei, deswegen habe ich es mitbekommen.
Das war der Skandal.
Das war auch ein Skandal, aber als ich dann anschließend das Heft in die Hand bekommen habe und dort die Platzierung gelesen habe und auch die Begründung, da waren wir vierter oder so, das war auch ein Skandal.
Aber worauf ich eigentlich hinauswollte, wir haben jetzt quasi eine Entwicklung nachverfolgt, dann habt ihr einen eigenen Podcast gestartet, Radio Rebell, das ist jetzt zeitlich nicht alles in der richtigen Reihenfolge, aber es gibt auch noch einen Podcast von euch. Du hast deine eigene Seite, in der du zu aller Arten Themen aus einem wissenschaftlichen Standpunkt… Ah ok, dann muss ich jetzt gar nicht sagen, dass es spektrograph.com heißt.
Die existiert noch wahrscheinlich für ein paar Wochen.
Ok, gut. Und dann ist es eine Seite. Also es ist sehr viel raus geworden. Wir haben die Lesetour, wo aus dem Herrenzieh, wir sammeln ein bisschen Geld, dann eben 10.000 Euro, 25.000 Euro wurden. Und jetzt sind wir eben schon jenseits der 30.000 Euro. Ihr habt über Filmrechte im Podcast auch immer wieder gesprochen. Da drängt sich die Frage auf, wie geht es jetzt weiter mit den Wochenendrebellen. Es sieht für mich nicht so aus, als ob irgendetwas ändern… enden würde. Und so komplett wird es mich auch nicht überraschen, wenn ihr in 10 Jahren die Welt übernommen hättet.
Also ich glaube, dass es so weitergeht. Wir werden jetzt erstmal die Blogs zusammenlegen. Ich glaube dadurch wird es noch mal organisatorisch einfacher. Also es wird allgemein so ein bisschen eine Umstrukturierung. Ich glaube der Blog wird dann… Es wird dann einfach mehr Regelmäßigkeit reinkommen. Es wird geordneter sein. Jeder wird gewisse Aufgaben haben müssen. Es werden die Kategorien geordneter sein. Es wird halt wirklich regelmäßig etwas erscheinen. Es wird so eine Art Redaktionsplan geben quasi.
Man kann die Begeisterung aus dem Gesicht des Vaters abheben.
Ich bin tatsächlich nur noch Redakteur dann. Es wird so sein, dass wir, so wie es immer geplant war, dass ich gesagt habe, irgendwann, also mein Ansatz war eigentlich, dass ich irgendwann Jason dann weiter über Fußballvereine oder über die Suche schreibt und dann selber da schreiben kann. Jetzt wird es halt zusammengelegt. Das heißt, es wird auch so einen wissenschaftlichen Touch noch bekommen. Mal gucken, wie wir das da so alles so runterbekommen auf der Seite. Aber ich habe ganz, ganz deutlich und unmissverständlich zu verstehen gegeben, ich bin dann nur noch der Redakteur. Also ich bin nicht der Bloginhaber. Ich muss liefern, aber bezahlt werde ich auch nicht.
Feste Freie. Noch frei in seiner Selbstbestimmung, aber schon fest an das Ding gewungen.
Im Podcast wird es jetzt erstmal so weitergehen, dass wir brauchen jetzt erstmal Stabilität, weil wir haben oder wir haben es jetzt, wir kriegen es mittlerweile hin, dass wir jetzt für jede Woche einen Wochenrückblick veröffentlichen. Das müssen wir erstmal so halten und das funktioniert bis jetzt auch nicht immer perfekt. Ja, wir haben es bis jetzt für jede Woche hingekriegt, aber es ist dann manchmal schon sehr spät oder wir müssen es machen, wenn wir vielleicht einfach eigentlich gar keinen Bock haben. Also da müssen wir noch ein bisschen, oder da müssen wir ja noch gucken, dass wir das besser organisieren, auch zeitlich. Aber Ziel ist schon, dass wir es jetzt schaffen, regelmäßig für jede Woche einen Wochenrückblick zu machen. Also dort erstmal die nötige Stabilität reinbekommen. Und natürlich dann, wenn man soweit ist, auch die Frequenz von den Losfolgen ein bisschen hoch zu bekommen, weil da machen wir momentan, wenn überhaupt, nur noch einmal im Monat.
Genau, muss man ganz kurz erklären. Da losst ihr ein Thema aus einer Lostrumme, wo ihr vorher jeder Zettel reingeschmissen habt und sprecht dann über dieses Thema.
Dann dazu wird es oder ich arbeite ja gerade an einem eigenen Buch, haben wir ja gerade darüber geredet. Als es um die Spendenziele gab, ging das Buch jetzt fertig. Er ist gerade im wissenschaftlichen Elektorat und die ersten Kapitel sind auch schon im Rechtschreib-Elektorat. Es wird dieses Jahr noch erscheinen über Crowdfunding. Es ist ein weitestgehend wissenschaftliches Buch. Es besteht aus drei Teilen grob. Der erste Teil ist eigentlich so ein naturalistisches Weltbild darüber, wie die Welt quasi entstanden ist. Also urknallend logisch, dann die frühe Entwicklung des Universums, Galaxien.
Die ersten sieben Tage der Schöpfung?
Die ersten 13 Milliarden Jahre der Schöpfung ungefähr. Dann, wie gesagt, Sterne, Planetenbildung, das Leben auf der Erde, also in der Ursuppe entstanden, die Evolution und die Entwicklung des Lebens auf der Erde eigentlich bis zur industriellen Revolution. Bis dahin kommt man eigentlich mit dem naturalistischen Weltbild weiter. Während es dann im zweiten Teil so ein bisschen um die heutige Gesellschaft geht und aus sehr, sehr verschiedenen und vielfältigen Perspektiven. Also es gibt einen Kapitel über die Digitalisierung, welches vielleicht auch philosophisch angehaut ist so ein bisschen. Es gibt einen Kapitel über die Urbanisierung, aber immer mit dem Hintergrund ökologisch. Das bedeutet, wie bekommt man welche ökologischen Vorteile hat vielleicht die Urbanisierung? Also das Städte wachsen, welche ökologischen Vorteile hat das? Globalisierung ist dort einmal drin, Naturkatastrophen, Bevölkerungswachstum, also einfach aus allen Perspektiven quasi. Während der dritte Teil, dort geht es dann eigentlich im Wesentlichen um die Zukunft. Und ja, zum ersten darum, wie die Zukunft aussehen wird, wenn wir jetzt so weitermachen und dann auch in einem Appell, in einem ziemlich radikalen Appell darum, was wir jetzt tun müssen, damit es sich eben zum Besseren wenden wird. Und eine Beschreibung, wie es dann halt dann werden wird.
Und wie wird das Buch heißen, wo wird man es bekommen können, was ist der Crowdfunding-Anteil daran?
Also das Buch wird Raumschiff Erde heißen, kommt von der Metapher Raumschiff Erde, die zur Zeit des Apollo-Programms so ein bisschen Aufschwung bekommen hat. Als quasi die Menschheit erstmal den Planeten Erde von außen gesehen hat, eigentlich als komplette Kugel dann vom Mond aus. Und da hat diese Metapher Raumschiff Erde so ein bisschen einen Aufschwung bekommen, weil man dort halt einfach gemerkt hat, die Erde ist nicht dieser unerschütterliche Boden, der irgendwie seit der Antike immer war, sondern sie ist eigentlich quasi eine Oase des Lebens in einem All, das eigentlich komplett lebensfeindlich ist. Und zu diesem Zeitpunkt waren dann auch, oder wenige Jahre später waren alle Planeten des Sonnensystems dann erforscht. Das bedeutet, zu dem Zeitpunkt wusste man dann auch, okay, dort draußen gibt es sonst nichts. Die Erde ist der einzige Planet, auf dem wir leben, und wir sind die Einzigen, die hier in der Nähe sind. Und wir sind quasi, wir sind niemanden gegenüber verpflichtet, aber wenn wir uns selbst erhalten wollen, was eigentlich unser oberstes Ziel ist, dass wir dann jetzt eben was ändern müssen, weil unsere Ressourcen halt nicht unbegrenzt sind und die Erde auch nicht unbegrenzt einstecken kann. Und das war halt dieser Beginn-Design-Metapher. Und deswegen ist, glaube ich, Raumschiff Erde dann abgewandelt zu Traumschiff Erde ein sehr passender Tippel. Und bekommen wird man es über Crowdfunding, wie gesagt. Crowdfunding-Kampagne haben wir uns schon entschieden, Kickstarter oder Startnext.
Ich habe dir beides zusammengefasst, entscheiden wirst du es dann.
Also über eine dieser beiden Plattformen wird es über Crowdfunding veröffentlicht werden.
Wenn da die Links kommen, dann werden sie auch nachträglich in den Show Notes noch eingefügt worden sein. Futur 2. Und wann kann ich euch jetzt dann in einer großen Hollywood-Produktion mit – ja, ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht, wie man sich da als Vater und wie man sich als Sohn wünschen könnte. Du hast ja schon mal Gedanken darüber gemacht, wer spielen soll.
Nein, ich kenne aber auch keine Schauspieler. Also wann, ich würde sagen, in zwei Jahren vielleicht. Vielleicht auch weniger.
Und dann wird es die Verfilmung eurer gemeinsamen Geschichte geben, oder?
Ich gehe schon davon aus, dass das kommen wird, ja.
Also das ist so, die Optionen auf die Filmrechte hat sich ja gesichert. Richard Kopf, der jetzt zuletzt mit Wanted und Four Blocks recht erfolgreich war.
Unsere Serie wird dann der Durchbruch, oder unser Film?
Absolut, genau. Jetzt ist er aktuell auf Vox, glaube ich, mit einer Serie hier noch. Und der ist Papa geworden dieses Jahr, sodass er gesagt hat, er wird also jetzt im September wohl soweit sein, dass er so mal die ersten Sequenzen, Passagen – ich bin jetzt auch kein Drehbuchautor, der weiß weder, wie man da so rangeht – aber es ist auf jeden Fall erstmal in Anbetracht der Situation, dass es wohl drei Interessenten für die Optionen der Filmrechte gab. Das eine war ein klassischer Verleih, der gesagt hat, komm, das nehmen wir uns jetzt einfach mal und gucken wir mal, wie das so weitergeht. Und da, in der Situation, war es halt so, dass es jemand war, wo man ein Gesicht dazu hatte, mit dem man sich auch mal treffen konnte und sagen konnte, was hast du eigentlich vor damit? Wie soll das so vonstattengehen? Der eine Affinität zu Fußball hat, eine ganz, ganz tiefe, zwar zu härter, ist halt so, gibt es soll es geben.
Fußball im weiteren Sinne.
Also im weiteren Sinne, ja. Aber der so ein bisschen in der Geschichte sich aus einem anderen Blickwinkel dann halt auch wiedergefunden hat, weil er mit seinem Dad halt auch sehr, sehr viel zum Fußball gegangen ist. Und der sich halt die gute Situation hat, gesichert hat, dass er, wenn er das Drehbuch geschrieben hat, er die Optionen auf die Filmrechte schon besitzt. Ob das dann tatsächlich jetzt so der Kinofilm wird, ob es vielleicht eher in Richtung einer Serie geht oder so. Also wenn ich jetzt so einfach mal sehe, die letzten vier Projekte, die wir gemacht haben, waren drei Serien eher so oder zumindest mehr Teiler. Das ist ja auch insgesamt eine Tendenz, die man da so beobachten kann. Oder ob es tatsächlich etwas ist, dass man merkt, das kriege ich gar nicht und da, gut, das siehst du wieder anders. Das weiß man nicht. Also er hat jetzt knappe anderthalb Jahre noch Zeit, die Optionen sind zeitlich begrenzt, dort etwas zu liefern, hat dann aber auch wieder Optionen, auch die wieder zu verlängern. Also das ist dann irgendwie alles vertraglich sehr ausgereift. Und dann muss man mal gucken, was da rauskommt. Das sehe ich noch sehr, sehr, sehr in weiter Ferne.
Wir sind so ein bis zwei Jahre.
Da gibt es dann die Netflix-Serie, die Wochenendrebellen, erst ganz viele Staffeln nacheinander und dann in der letzten Folge wirst du Fan des FC Bayern in der Allianz Arena. Und dann ruft der alte Betreuer aus dem Verlag nochmal an und sagt, ich hätte das schneller gewusst.
Es wird dann wieder so eine Serie werden, die wahrscheinlich niemals endet. Es endet irgendwie nach zwölf Staffeln.
Hauptsache, das Ende ist nicht so wie in Lost.
Was ist denn in Lost?
Schlecht. Es wird nicht dem Spannungsbogen.
In der Serie wäre das echt ein Problem. Mit sehr hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit wäre das Ende der Serie, das ich im Verein nicht gefunden habe.
Wo die Frage ist, kann das dann ein Ende sein?
Muss es ja.
Ja, wir können ja mal gucken. Ich würde es euch zutrauen, dass ihr die erste nicht endende Serie erfindet und es dann einfach immer weitergeht.
Im Grunde ist es ja so. Irgendwann hat man mit drei Spiele ganz oder eine Staffel.
Ich mag das, wie du denkst, Jason. Kannst du mir später noch verraten, wie wir den Rasenfunk noch... Also in eurem Windschatten können wir vielleicht auch größer und bekannter werden. Da gehen wir noch mal ins Einzelcoaching danach. Gibt noch einen Aspekt, auf den würde ich gerne ganz zum Schluss noch zu sprechen kommen, weil dem auch ein eigenes Kapitel gewidmet ist und weil ich vermute, dass am Anfang dieser Folge da auch einige Hörerinnen und Hörer ein paar Fragen im Kopf hatten, nämlich wie ist das, was ihr jetzt gemacht habt, all die letzten Jahre mit Familienleben vereinbar, Mirko?
Das ist ähnlich wie die Frage, wenn man dann so liest, was wir so alles gemacht haben, wenn dann jemand sagt, wie schafft ihr das alles oder so. Ich mag die Frage einerseits, weil sie immer so im Unterton suggeriert, dass es tatsächlich so wäre, dass wir alles schaffen, was überhaupt nicht so ist.
Aber irgendwie schaffen wir es ja.
Ja, es kommt ja immer darauf an, wie man alles definiert. Und wenn ich jetzt erstmal alles definiere, dass ich gerne eine enge Bindung zu meiner Tochter hätte, dass ich gerne regelmäßig Zeit für meine Frau hätte, dann ist es erstmal nicht so, dass wir das alles schaffen.
Zeit hast du, sie wollen nur nicht mitkommen. Das ist keine zeitliche Sache, sondern eine Willensfrage.
Ja gut, dass jetzt die Lani nicht zwingt, ihre Zeit mit mir bei minus 4 Grad beim VFR allen verbringt, ist vielleicht auch ein Nachverzweifler.
Wir sind ja auch auf sie zugegangen. Hauptsache, ich bin halt mit dem Zug unterwegs. Ich würde auch woanders hinfahren. Aber wenn sie grundsätzlich nicht darauf einigen können, dass gemeinsame Zeit schon im Zug unterwegs verbrachte Zeit ist, dann muss man vielleicht akzeptieren, dass es keine Lösung gibt.
Das ist ja das, wo ich dir gesagt habe, dass ich schon durchaus sehe, dass es dort Lösungen gibt. Aber da sehe ich es ja nicht zwingend so, dass die Idealsituation wäre natürlich schon, dass wir als gesamte Familie auch funktionieren irgendwo in einer gewissen Art und Weise. Das finde ich halt, dass wir da noch ein gutes Stückchen von wechseln, sondern es ist eigentlich immer so gebildete Teams, die wir dort sind. Das wäre so die Idealsituation, wenn es im Gesamtpaket nicht klappt. Also wir haben vor zwei Jahren versucht, irgendwie einen gemeinsamen Urlaub zu organisieren.
Das ist so gescheitert, das kann man sich nicht vorstellen.
Das ist pfleglich gescheitert, weil er dann, ne, wenn wir da fliegen, nein.
Das war bürokratisch, weil es kam halt wirklich so, irgendwie jeder hat schon so versucht, irgendwie seinen Standpunkt durchzusetzen. Es gab Familiensitzungen, ich glaube wir haben insgesamt zehn Sitzungen damit verbracht. Und wir haben dann letzten Endes, war es sogar so weit, dass irgendwie Mami und Papsi sich zusammengetan haben und gesagt haben, okay, sie müssen irgendwie Lani's Interessen gegenüber meinen verteidigen. Und dann haben sie dann so gespaltene Gruppen entwickelt, dass, ja, wie er es dann irgendwann gesagt hat, es hat keinen Sinn.
Das ist ja wie eine UN-Simulation bei euch zu Hause.
Ja, so diese Familienvereinbarungssitzungen und Verhandlungen, da ist, ich wünschte dann immer, ich wäre bei den Brexit-Verhandlungen, dann geht es dann einfach zur Sache. Nein, aber um das zum Ende zu bringen, da sehe ich, insbesondere wenn man dann im Buch aussieht, was so das Ziel eigentlich ist, dann ist es, ich habe es geschafft, meine Jobsituation zu verändern in den letzten zwei Jahren. Ich arbeite immer noch viel, aber durchaus ein gewisser Flexibler. Es gibt regelmäßig sowas wie freie Tage. Das gab es sehr, sehr viele Jahre nicht. Ich nehme auch meinen Urlaub jetzt plötzlich, wo ich sonst immer gesagt habe, das geht ja gar nicht, dass ich 14 Tage weg bin oder so. Den nehme ich jetzt immer. Und da ist so vieles auf den Weg gebracht. Das Problem ist, oder das Problem, was ich noch sehe, die Zeit, die gewonnen ist, wurde nicht gefüllt mit Gesamtfamilienzeit, sondern mit Lesereise, Koordination von Lesereisen etc. Ich meine, er hilft wirklich, wo er kann. Ich will Jason da überhaupt keinen Vorwurf machen, aber es ist halt auch schon so. Es gibt Lesungen, wie jetzt hier in München im Stadion an der Schlaßeimer Straße. Das ist eine Mail. Dann sagt er, jawohl, Termin, okay, alles klar, dann und dann Uhrzeit, okay, super, brauchst du noch was? Nö, passt. Dann hört man sich drei Monate nicht, dann fährt man zur Lesung, alles ist schick und alles ist fein. Es gibt aber auch Lesungen, da gehen 28 Mails hinterher, du musst dann noch mal eine Ausweiskopie einreichen, du sollst am besten persönlich vorstellig werden, um noch mal zu gucken, was ist da eigentlich los etc. Also es ist dann teilweise schon immer mit immensem Aufwand verbunden. Oder auch die Koordination dieser Medientermine, wo du dann halt guckst, machst du das, machst du das nicht, dann mit den Jason abstimmen, was hältst du davon, dann noch mal gucken, ok, was ist da die Intention, dann wieder nachtelefonieren. Sodass die gewonnene Zeit nicht dafür genutzt wurden konnte, dass ich mich um die beiden Menschen kümmere, die es jetzt eigentlich am notwendigsten gehabt hätten, und das sind meine Frau und meine Tochter.
Aber das ist wieder dieses Parteiendenken, was du gerade hast. Du hast jetzt wieder nur von den beiden gesprochen. Wieso sollte ich irgendwas zustimmen, was das Gleichgewicht nicht zu meinen Gunsten verleiht?
Nein, nein, ich habe ja nicht gesagt, dass ich irgendwas zustimme. Ich habe nur gesagt, wenn ich überlege, dass damals die Ist-Situation etwas war, womit wir nicht zufrieden waren, womit ich nicht zufrieden war, womit deine Mama nicht zufrieden war und womit auch Lani nicht zufrieden war. Du warst zufrieden, dass es etwas ist, dass man dort Zeitfenster herausgewinnen musste, was uns gelungen ist, aber diese Zeitfenster nicht gleichmäßig dazu geführt haben, dass wir als Familie funktionieren.
Wir konnten uns nicht auf Dinge einigen, die wir machen.
Das hatte damit weniger zu tun, sondern das hat eher damit zu tun, dass wir durch 40 Städte getingelt sind, um die Lesereise zu machen, die du auf der Bühne großzügig angekündigt hast, was wir jetzt noch alles machen.
Die hätten mitkommen können.
Ja, aber du kannst ja nicht freies Recht auf Selbstbestimmung, nur wenn es dich selbst betrifft. In dem Moment hat es schon mal mich betroffen und es hat deine Schwester betroffen und es hat deine Mama betroffen.
Mami und Lani könnten ja auch ruhig mal selbst die Initiative übernehmen und Dinge sagen, wo sie hinfahren wollen oder die sie machen wollen. Also es kam ja auch nicht besonders viel Input jetzt von dort.
Gut, da ist ja auch nicht mehr viel Input zu machen, wenn wir die ganze Zeit unterwegs sind. Gut, also das wäre so ein bisschen die Situation, die wir sicherlich unterschiedlich betrachten. Aber wo ich sagen würde, ich bin sehr froh, wir haben jetzt noch eine Lesung im August, sind wir noch mal in Gelsenkirchen. Das war so unsere Desaster-Lesung bisher. Da standen wir im strömenden Regen vor drei Leuten.
Weil die Lesung eigentlich abgesagt wurde?
Weil die Lesung eigentlich abgesagt wurde und er dann gesagt hat, nein, das akzeptiere ich nicht, wir fahren da trotzdem hin. Also standen wir da auf dem Marktplatz sonntags Mittags, mitten im Regen, die Veranstalterin, ich glaube, die hat ihre Tochter noch rangeschleppt, damit sie nicht ganz alleine da ist. Und vom Web 04, vom Schalkeblock kam tatsächlich noch jemand, der hat gesagt, ich erbarme mich und gucke mir das mit an. Und da sind wir jetzt noch mal im August. Und dann machen wir quasi zu unserem Geburtstag rund um den im Oktober 18. 19.10. machen wir Plauen und Chemnitz hintereinander. Und dann ist immer noch offen Rostock, weil wir dort jetzt gesehen haben, dass die Spieltagsansetzung für die dritte Liga, die durch sind, wieder so die Rostock Heimspiele liegen, dass es nicht passt. Und wir werden Ende August, werden wir noch so unseren persönlichen Abschluss haben, so ein bisschen mit dieser Lesereise, dass wir nochmal auf einem Festival lesen dürfen. Das hatten wir, da die Möglichkeit hatten wir uns letztes Jahr.
Dann wird es weitergehen mit meinem Buch, da wird es wahrscheinlich auch einige Lesungen geben. Aber nicht so viele wahrscheinlich, aber es wird, ich glaube, mit meinem Buch wird es keine Lesereise in 40 Städten geben, aber es wird schon einige Lesungen geben.
Ja, sodass dann, ich sag mal so Mitte Oktober, dann wirklich, dann ist, was das angeht, Feierabend, bis dahin ist auch der Blog übergeben und dann werde ich mein Wochenendrebellen-Rentner da sein, beziehungsweise Zulieferer für den Blog werde ich dann noch sein. Aber mehr ist dann nicht.
Aber ich glaube, mehr Zeit mit Ami Ullani werden wir dann immer noch nicht verbringen.
Sprich bitte für dich, bei mir kann ich dir ganz sicher sagen, dass das so sein wird.
Glaubst du, wir haben uns bis dahin geeinigt auf etwas, was wir so sagen können? Optimistisch. Wenn man mal guckt, dass wir seit anderthalb Jahren über eine CO2-Steuer diskutieren und noch nicht mal eine Absichtserklärung unterschrieben haben, dass wir sie jetzt in einem halben Jahr hinkriegen, das größte Problem, was wir eigentlich derzeit haben, zu lösen.
Redest du jetzt gerade von der familieninternen CO2-Steuer oder war das ein Vergleich zur…
Ja, das war die familieninterne CO2-Steuer.
Trotz der Reduktion. Na ja, letzte Woche wurde in der Familienansetzung noch gefeiert, dass wir schon so weit gekommen sind, insgesamt, was CO2-Reduktion angeht.
Wir waren vor zwei Jahren bei 15 Tonnen CO2-Äquivalenten pro Person pro Jahr. Der deutsche Durchschnitt sind 11, jetzt sind wir bei 6. Aber wir brauchen zwei, um den Klimawandel aufzuhalten. Deswegen kann man ja durchaus aus beiden Perspektiven sehen. Wir sind mittlerweile deutlich unter dem deutschen Durchschnitt, aber wir sind auch immer noch deutlich über dem, was wir brauchen.
Es wird immer weitergehen. Man kann viel teilhaben, weil ihr uns teilhaben lasst, an auch solchen Diskussionen. Da kann man euren Podcast sehr empfehlen unter www.wochenendrebellen.de. Da kann man sich in einem Newsletter eintragen. Da bekommt man auf jeden Fall alle Infos und verpasst sie dann auch nicht. Und jedem und jeder, der oder die das Buch noch nicht gelesen hat, das wollen wir euch wirklich ans Herz legen da draußen. Wir Wochenendrebellen heißt es. Ein ganz besonderer Junge und sein Vater auf Stadion Tour durch Europa gibt es als Paperback und als Taschenbuch. Und dann sind wir sehr gespannt auf das Traumschiff Erde, was dann irgendwann im Herbst kommen wird, wo dann nochmal ein anderer Fokus gelegt wird. Ich würde sagen, auch wenn wir knapp die 4 Stunden nicht reißen werden, Jason.
Wie viel haben wir denn?
3, 54 ca. Es wird ja noch eine Kleinigkeit rausgeschnitten, deswegen kann ich es dir nicht exakt sagen. 3, 5. Dir würde ich sogar als einzigen Gast bisher erlauben, wenn dir die 4 Stunden wichtig sind, dass du noch 5 Minuten über etwas redest, was dir wichtig ist. Nein. Okay, dürfen wir so Schluss machen. Wir können nicht anders als uns sehr herzlich zu bedanken für die Zeit, die ihr euch genommen habt, dass ihr hierher gekommen seid, dass ihr den Aufwand auf euch genommen habt, dass ihr über alle Dinge so offen geredet habt, dass jede Frage hier beantwortet wurde mit einer bemerkenswerten Offenheit. Ja, vielen herzlichen Dank, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen, verfolgt die beiden sehr gerne in den sozialen Netzwerken. Alles wird in den Show Notes verlinkt sein, sowie noch ein paar sehr schöne Artikel, die es zu den Wochenendrebellen gibt. Wir haben nicht mal über alles hier gesprochen. Es ist kaum zu glauben. In diesem Sinne, das war Tribünengespräch Nummer 36. Herzlichen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Solltet ihr noch nicht alle Tribünengespräche gehört haben, dann widmet euch doch auch gerne mal den älteren Folgen. Und ansonsten hören wir uns wieder hier im Rasenfunk. Frank und Max sagen Danke. Macht's gut. Ciao.
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.